yeah
members take your seats please
the house will come to order
[Music]
members take your seats please
don't
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who's at
the house adjourned from the session of
february 16 2022
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the house is
adjourned
the house will attend to a prayer by
house chaplain reverend bob stewart
pastor of saint paul's united methodist
church in manchester
thank you mr speaker
let us be in a spirit of prayer
a loving creator of the universe
thank you for every seat that has been
filled here today
for each mind and heart that fills the
presence of this room we thank you
only you truly know what we are setting
out to accomplish today
we have an idea
a vision
hints
and daily instructions
we have talents
abilities and time to work
however only you can see in perfect
detail
the end of every beginning oh god you
are the alpha and the omega
you are the beginning and the end
you are everything
every project
every season
every life
nothing is ever in vain
for even mistakes and missteps are used
for something good
your righteousness transcends all our
efforts and understanding
guide and direct us this day as we seek
a better way
and a better life in this world that you
have created
help us to make decisions that will be
good for those we represent
in this great state of new hampshire
strengthen our confidence in who you
have made us to be
set us free from comparison in order to
work together
efficiently and in harmony
we thank you for the leadership that is
represented here today
bless this meeting today all those
present
as well as the lives of those we will
encounter afterwards
ready us to make every moment count this
day
and in the days ahead
we pray all this in your name who is god
of us all
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
portsmouth joan hamblet who will now
lead us in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which he stands
one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
please remain standing for the plane of
the national anthem
[Music]
so
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leads of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch cushing ellis
frost mary griffin guthrie kimball miler
richards roy peter schmidt spang tudor
welch the day important business
representatives baxter cody kennedy
lundgren o'hara sanborn southworth
barney verville walls the day illness in
the family representatives elliot and
rhodes
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
before we go any further
we still have 30 bills that we have to
finish after today i mean after the
governor's address
some of them have some pretty decent
debates on them
yesterday
the noise
in this building was unacceptable
and i'm addressing this to both caucuses
it was totally unacceptable
this would never have happened if we
were in the chamber
this is the house chamber
i hope everybody takes notice
and respects the fact that there is
supposed to be no talking in the chamber
if you want to have a conversation take
it outside
house will attend to a resolution
mr speaker
representatives osborne and evil offer
the following resolve that the house of
representatives notify the honorable
senate that it is ready to meet and join
convention for the purpose of hearing
the state of the state address by his
excellency the governor christopher t
sununu
question is on the resolution are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those close nay
the eyes have it and the resolution is
adopted
the house will attend to a senate
message
mr speaker
the senate is ready to meet with the
honorable house of representatives and
joint convention for the purpose of
hearing the state of the state address
by his excellency governor christopher t
sununu
the sergeant-at-arms will escort our
guests as they are introduced by the
clerk
recognizes the clerk
mr speaker the honorable senate and
president of the senate the honorable
chuck morris of salem
[Applause]
senate president
joint convention will come to order the
chair recognizes the clerk
mr speaker the acting secretary of state
david m scanlon
[Applause]
chair recognizes the clerk
mr speaker the new hampshire state
treasurer the honorable monica meza pele
[Applause]
the chair recognizes the clerk
mr speaker executive counselor
representing district one the honorable
joseph d kenny
[Applause]
yes
jerick and isa is the clerk
mr speaker the chief justice of the new
hampshire supreme court the honorable
gordon j mcdonald esquire
[Applause]
all right
everybody can take a seat for a minute
while we wait for the governor
oh okay all right i got mine
this is
um
well no it's an otpa
yes literally literally everything in
science
yep
well then we've got all the ones
unhappy
no no you should
so
that's not
oh
place back there
yes
john
uh
morning
[Music]
so
this right here
you give it two minute warning please
members will return to their seats
members please take your seats
members take your seats please
two minutes from now
coffee on that
members take your seats please
members members will return to their
seats
so
j recognizes the clerk
mr speaker his excellency the governor
christopher t sununu
[Applause]
so
the joint convention and guests will now
be attentive to the governor's state of
the state address the chair recognizes
the governor christopher t sununu
[Applause]
please
well good morning
i gotta get settled i'm looking for the
button
where the podium raises
from the speaker no offense
my dad used to have the same problem
five foot six
um
well good morning it is uh really great
to be here um it has obviously been a
long time since we've been able to
gather together
obviously mr speaker and mr senate
president um thank you very much
obviously the esteemed members of our
house our the esteemed uh state senate
uh members of the executive council
chief justice mcdonald great to see you
this morning um
so
it has been a long year to be sure
i think we were all looking forward to
2021 a racing 2020
but we had challenges ahead of us
without a doubt and so what i wanted to
do this morning is talk a little bit
about some of the things that we've
encountered
i think how we faced a lot of those
challenges in that i think it sets a
model for how to be proactive how to be
positive how not to back away from
things and then really look forward
prospectively in terms of what we can
get done i think in the next year
there's no doubt that we have set a lot
of good standards and good models and we
can build off that to be sure
but
let's start a little bit behind us in
terms of covet right since we've all
gotten together two years ago it was i
think uh
february
of 2020 just before the pandemic hit
this state
we have to recognize that we have lost
over
2300 individuals to covet and i think i
speak for all of us when i say that our
hearts just go out to their those
families go out to those individuals
who have had to deal with this pandemic
and this tragedy uh who that hit us hard
we didn't see it coming but we buckled
down
covet has been very tough but new
hampshire has been very strong
we're resilient we're putting systems
and policies in place that don't just
make us like everybody else right
they separate us from the pack and i
think they really capitalize on a lot of
the opportunity we have uh right here in
the granite state
so let's jump into a little bit of an
update let's start with some good news
right we don't want to always start on
the negative you have to acknowledge the
negative but there has been some really
good news
especially in the past year today the
granite state
we are ranked as the freest nation the
free estate in the nation we have the
strongest economy in the northeast we
have the fastest population growth in
the northeast we're number one in
america for public safety we are first
in america for economic freedom and we
continue to have the lowest poverty rate
and some of the highest wages in this
country those are big wins for our
citizens
so when you go down that list you can
see ranking after ranking shows that the
granite state is the place to be america
not just new england but america is
truly taking notice
uh we are very proud that our way of
life here in the 603 is simply the best
of the best but we did not get here by
accident right we did it through smart
management
tough work prioritizing individuals over
government prioritizing citizens over
systems
and delivering results with the immense
responsibility
of managing our taxpayer dollars and
knowing that you have to balance budgets
because i believe as in the public
sector there's no greater responsibility
than managing someone else's money and
this legislature has done a tremendous
job
so as as other states we saw other
states across this country really buckle
down to weather the storm of 2021 but we
took a much more proactive approach in
the past year
in just the last year we've cut the
statewide property tax we talk about
property taxes all the time and this
legislature cut it by a hundred million
dollars
we cut the room in meals tax we cut
business taxes again
and we're now permanently phasing out
our interest in dividends taxes again
reducing that burden on our citizens
[Applause]
and those were tough decisions to make
without a doubt we heard a lot of scary
stories how if you cut taxes
you know we wouldn't have money to push
down to the cities and towns if he cut
taxes we're going to have to slash all
of our programs
but the way we design this has played
out exactly as we anticipated we cut
taxes
and what happened
we've now exceeded all of our
expectations in terms of surpluses and
we've doubled the rainy day fund to over
250 million dollars
look a few years ago you guys were here
a few years ago we would get excited if
we had a surplus of 25 million oh that
gives us a lot of opportunity we manage
well we balance the budget we have some
opportunity to spend in a little
infrastructure what's the situation
today we're going to have about 10 times
that amount again to make real long-term
investments in infrastructure and make
sure we do it without putting any
additional burden
onto our citizens and at at the state
level we've had great financial success
by cutting these taxes and drawing all
of this business in right but let's not
forget local governments as well have
had unprecedented amounts of financial
opportunity
federal support has been very powerful
here in the state there's no doubt about
that federal support has put over 600
million dollars into our education
system alone
uh over the next couple years then you
add the other 250 million dollars
dollars in dollars spent
you had another 250 million dollars in
the general federal support that came
through the arpa funding that goes down
to every city every town every county in
the state and then you add on what this
legislature did with a hundred million
dollars of property tax relief
with the fact that not only did we cut
room and meals tax here's an amazing
thing we cut meals and rooms tax for all
our citizens and we increased the amount
we're sending back to cities and towns
thanks to senator rachardi over there
we're increasing that by 45 percent
back to cities and towns
cut taxes up here cut taxes for citizens
send more back to cities and towns it's
an incredible amount of money to offset
a lot of those local costs so instead of
downshifting costs which we hear a lot
about you know historically decades ago
we're now downshifting cash
and that's a win for our citizens
because in these with these investments
what we're seeing is many towns are now
lowering their property taxes i i got to
be honest if your town is not lowering
their property taxes town meeting is
like a month right
go to town meeting fight for because
your towns have unprecedented amount of
money unprecedented amount of
opportunity and so while the state can't
control cutting property taxes by
sending this opportunity back to cities
and towns yet again it takes that
pressure off the entire system and
creates opportunities that a lot of
folks never thought that they would see
now
we let me let's take a little bit of a
step back with cove right it's still
here we know we're going to be grappling
that with a while
so last year our nation continued
through the covet pandemic it strained
our health care system we saw that very
upfront and personal it tested us like
never before we're still dealing with
things that a lot of us never thought
we'd have to deal with in terms of the
public sector or our private lives or
with our businesses
and while other states while the surge
that winter surge really hit the country
other states were
you could watch them they were kind of
caught flat-footed
but we took a forward-looking
perspective we prepared for what we knew
would be a tough winter back in the
summer and fall dr chan and commissioner
shiban and i were talking about that
winter surge preparing for that winter
surge and we knew that government can't
solve cove government is not going to be
able to solve a viral pandemic
but when we came together
we cut red tape we flexed open our
health care system to meet our citizens
needs
and so what were the results of that
well when you look at what's happened
just over the past year new hampshire
was the fastest state in the country
with the initial vaccine rollout which
meant that we were the first state in
the country to really allow vaccines for
anyone who wanted it again creating a
lot of flexibility
you look at what we've done recently we
delivered one and a half million
home free home tests click a button two
days later amazon was dropping them on
your doorstep we did that twice and then
the federal government realized that we
had a pretty darn good model and they
well they copied it although i saw the
wmur story last night they're not doing
a very good job with that i don't know
who ordered the free test from the
federal government apparently they're
still figuring out postage or something
people are waiting weeks for those
things but
leave it to the feds to screw up a good
idea but here in new hampshire we did it
really well
we did it really well and the fact is we
did it so well you had the federal
government copying our our program and
we're able to kind of do it a third time
with what we're with the availability of
tests that we now have coming out of our
liquor stores
we we looked looked at what was going to
happen in our classrooms we looked at
how hard those last those i guess those
spring months of 2020 had been on our
kids and we said we're going to keep our
schools open and we're going to keep
schools children safely in our
classrooms we built out internal surge
centers within the hospitals we cut red
tape we fast tracked hundreds of new
nursing licenses in just a few weeks in
december we cut that red tape we moved
it forward and we got those folks on the
floors of our hospitals it was really
awesome
we strategically deployed a lot of the
dollars to help our health care
providers and our long-term providers
our long-term care providers
and then when the federal government
continually kept mixing the messages up
right that say one thing one week one
thing the next we were out there every
week trying to kind of straighten it out
as best we could for our citizens there
was a lot of mismanagement at the
federal level and so then they panicked
and they came down with their illegal
mandates and we stood up against the
illegal mandates and we won and we beat
them back in court for our citizens and
for our businesses
so we know we've new hampshire has
consistently ranked amongst being one of
the safest states when it comes to covet
now having one of the lowest
hospitalization rates in the country and
we did it without sacrificing those
freedoms that we hold dear we kept
businesses open and we let individuals
and communities decide what was going to
best work for them but we also didn't go
to extremes we didn't tell small
businesses who you could hire and who
you could fire we know it's not right to
infringe on those businesses rights and
it is not what the live free or die
state is all about
we used a team approach
everything has to be team it wasn't just
me sitting up here you know dictating
from from the top those models don't
work right by incorporating the
legislature by incorporating the fiscal
committee by incorporating
our teams at health and human services
and the department of public health
making sure we put all those ideas on
the table
we listen to our citizens we engage them
we ask them what they thought in these
processes we let them take the
responsibility
of figuring out
where we could go where we could go
locally
it's never easy to be sure it's not a
one size fits all we had some tough
battles not just at the state level but
at the local level you see some of those
conversations happening to be sure
but the nation has taken notice
the nation has taken notice of our
success and we've achieved them here in
new hampshire
so when we look at crafting guidance to
keep the economy open that was done
because we asked businesses and citizens
what they wanted to see
when we looked at the resiliency that we
could deliver as granite staters and how
that translated to actually what was
happening in our neighborhoods in our
communities
we weren't resilient because the
government said be resilient
we were resilient because we believed in
the individual we were resilient because
we believed that we could communicate
and have some tough battles over some of
these issues but get to a place where at
the end of the day it really really
worked
so now we're moving forward
in the state and we're moving forward
with the mindset that covid may be here
for quite some time is it going to be
gone this summer i would love to be able
to say it is but we don't know that
could be here for years
but we can manage
we can absolutely manage we have the
model
and now it's time that we turn new
normal remember that term let's turn new
normal back to old normal the pandemic
of 2022
is not like march of 2020 because we
have so many more tools in our toolbox
we have the vaccines we have boosters we
have the at home tests we know so much
more we continue to let data and science
dictate where we go with some of these
decisions just as we have since the very
beginning
but let's also recognize a group of
individuals that i know we all want to
thank
none of this is possible right just
because government says so no matter how
good we are at this level
it's only possible when you look at
flexing open that health care system
those health care workers those doctors
those nurses our national guard who
stepped up time and time again
i just want to take this moment on
behalf of everyone in this room and
simply say thank you
[Music]
so
i take that step back and i talk about
how we did it not just what we did what
we did was pretty great
but how we did it is very important as
well
and i know i'm reading my speech here
and i'm kind of going through a lot of
this in my head i i know it must sound
like i'm spending a lot of time just
bashing on washington but at the end of
the day that's where it all gets bogged
up we know that that's no secret
right when you get into washington dc
and unlike washington dc
when we say we're going to do something
we do it
it doesn't mean we have the end-all
be-all answer but we figure it out
because that's the job that we were
hired to do
and i think we can all agree that it's a
long time coming that frankly
politicians in washington could take a
playbook out of new hampshire not out of
one party or another but out of the fact
that frankly we're a purple state and we
still find a way to get things done
through politics policy we can still
find a way to make sure that at the end
of the day we're getting results that's
what we're hired to do we're delivering
something
so instead of that partisan bickering
that perpetual gridlock we see
we know that complacency
it's not in our dna this is new
hampshire after all right it's not who
we are as granite staters
states are the ones that are really
leading the management of this pandemic
and the pandemic the opportunity with
cutting taxes the opportunity with
taking some financial burden off
individuals those are states that are
driving them the states of the
laboratories of democracy and thanks to
that no-nonsense approach
that we design
here in new hampshire with those
flexible systems we meet the needs of
our citizens so we had a great year last
year all things being considered it was
a great year a great year of opportunity
but there's a lot more to be done
so last year when i delivered my
inaugural address it was a little
different i was i had to do it in the
television studio i don't know if
anybody watched
a little weird because i'm more i like
to have more conversations as opposed to
just delivering speeches and all of that
but
one thing that i really tried to focus
on last year coming out of 2020 was the
idea that we all have to come together
it doesn't mean we all agree
but we all have to find the path
so that we can head into that new year
united
not necessarily on politics or policy
again but united as granite staters
united with the responsibility that i
know the 400 plus individuals in this
room i think do collectively share
when you break through that ugly
political divide and you see that ugly
political divide in a lot of other
places
we can we can and have shown that we can
get some amazing things done so last
year let's talk about some real
initiatives that i challenge folks with
and i know some of them were popular
some of them weren't popular some of
them needed to be hashed out a little
more than maybe we were ready to do
but let's talk about some really
innovative things we didn't just sit on
the sidelines and say well let's just
pass you know the budget let's just keep
things going and we'll let we'll see
what happens with covid we took the
opportunity to still jump on to certain
initiatives last year i talked about
paid family league delivering it without
an income tax and the result isn't we
just didn't talk about it we actually
passed that program and right now we're
developing frankly one of the most
innovative versions of paid leave that
you're going to find anywhere in the
country
we we talked about educational
opportunity right we talked we've talked
about it for years and we we've nipped
around the edges here and there we've
done some really good things with
educational opportunity but this year
for the first time in our state's
history
a child's zip code and their family's
income no longer determine their
educational options with education
our education savings accounts
are providing opportunity not just to a
couple hundred but thousands of families
across the state
a concept an idea and an opportunity
they never even imagined that they would
they would ever have and again we didn't
just talk about it we found a way to do
it we got it done and an unprecedented
number of families are taking advantage
of it with nothing but successful
results we've always we talked about
prioritizing cutting taxes attracting
businesses so you cut them and you cut
them and then we cut them again
now we know we have one of the lowest
tax burdens in our in the country all
while still delivering some of the most
robust services in the country in fact
new hampshire is ranked number one in
the country for the dollars into the
system compared to what you get out we
get a better rate of return for our tax
dollars than anywhere else and so while
you cut taxes you create financial
opportunity and you can still deliver on
the obligations that you have to from a
government perspective
and
again we talk about people taking notice
how do i know we have the fastest
population growth in the northeast that
hasn't happened in a long time
businesses are absolutely pouring in
here
and we have the largest state surplus in
the state's history the tax cuts work
let's do it again let's do it again
you know here's one that we haven't
talked about lately back in 2016
remember new hampshire had some of the
highest health care costs in the country
it was a real issue the fact that we
were kind of up here in the northeast
some of the highest health care costs in
the country and we didn't just accept it
we set out to change it so we changed
certain regulatory barriers at the state
level we changed certain policies and
what's the result this year we have the
lowest benchmark health insurance
premiums in new england and we are now
below the national average in terms of
health insurance and health costs you
guys did that
so one of the issues that we talk a lot
about is mental health right
this is a national issue i frankly i
think it's a worldwide issue
and we continue to take that challenge
head on
when i came into office the state had a
mental health system that was fragmented
it was designed by bureaucrats it didn't
work for families and we called it the
unspoken crisis of our time and
unfortunately that had only been
exacerbated by the coveted pandemic
it was no accident when i decided to
choose for my commissioner of health and
human services a nurse
that had worked her way up through the
long term care system that had managed
new hampshire hospital
i know a lot of folks obviously they see
her on tv with me a lot of folks have
gotten to know commissioner shibanen
but working with her and her team
we set out to dramatically transform the
entire mental health system not just a
piece of it here not just put a little
more money in there but really transform
the system to acknowledge that it is
and to do things like it's 1985 doesn't
make any sense and it doesn't deliver
results
and as we came through last year's covet
emergency order i immediately issued
another executive order if you remember
and we just simply called on direct
action to ensure that individuals in the
mental health crisis especially kids
receive timely and appropriate medical
medical care simple statement something
everybody can agree on but you can't
just have a blue ribbon commission you
can't just write an executive order and
tuck it away
in a drawer somewhere
so a key piece of that transformation
effort as a lot of us know is to
increase capacity in our community based
services getting your services getting
your mental health supports getting a
lot of your health care supports in your
community is simply a better way to do
it
so that provide means providing access
to mental health care for children and
families before they find themselves in
the crisis before they walk in to have
to walk into that emergency room
so
let's talk about a couple of our
successes and i think they set a model
for where we go as a lot of folks know
we recently signed a purchase and sales
agreement to buy hampstead hospital it's
a transformational investment to provide
dedicated services specifically for new
hampshire's kids who need and deserve
access to high quality mental health
providers
last month
last just last month we doubled down our
on our emergency on-demand access to
mental health so when you're in a crisis
you don't have time to wait
it isn't something that you want to
study we need the middle
middle of a mental health crisis we
should be asking people to google where
to find supports so now we have our
mobile prices support a 24 7 crisis call
center
over the last year we invested millions
to promote youth activities as well not
just what we do in the classroom we have
great social emotional learning programs
in the classroom we're working with kids
to understand some of the
pressures that can be on them and on the
system and how to work that we're doing
it through our summer camp programs
outside of the classroom with kids
something that we had never even tried
before but had tremendous success with
and i'm calling on the house and senate
today while i got you i got a captive
audience right
so we've made great progress
sb 234 it's something that i find so
simple
but i think it's actually a brilliant
idea and sometimes the best ideas can
can come in the simplest ways it simply
requires that every student id in new
hampshire have the phone number to the
national suicide prevention lifeline a
24 7 emergency service that is now in
the pocket of every kid with access to
every family member it's so simple it
costs nothing but will undoubtedly save
lives
but we're not done
not by any means
uh in the next few weeks commissioner
shibane and i will be bringing forward a
history another i think historic
opportunity for a public private
partnership
that will for the first time provide new
hampshire with an adequate number of
crisis beds for those who are most in
need
making investments in two brand new
mental health hospitals in this state
will have a profound effect not just
creating access to the beds but also by
opening the door
and getting a level of workforce that
we've never seen in mental health a
level of specialization that we need
here in the state we now become one of
the most attractive places on the east
coast
for mental health workers for that
workforce for new programs and new ideas
and these investments are going to be
coming i hope to get everybody's support
we're not we're not done
just because we're investing in these
new hospitals we're taking better
community services we're making it a
little easier for someone in that moment
of prices in their home to access help
we can't just rest on that
there's going to be a lot more ideas
that come to the table every one of
those ideas has to be put on that table
every one of those ideas has to be
listened to because whatever we design
and invest in today we can't do what we
did three decades ago make fundamental
change and then just kind of rest on our
laurels sit back go on to the next thing
the mental health challenges that our
country and our state are going to face
are going to be here for some time the
doors are open it's a community solution
it's a 10-year mental health plan that
was designed by families not bureaucrats
think about that for a second right
we didn't just have bureaucrats right we
ran the families to do it that was hard
it was a lot of hard work but allowing
those ideas to come on the table opened
our eyes to a world of opportunity
problems challenges we're taking them
head on
so there's a lot to do and all i ask is
what i think everybody in this room can
agree can agree with that when it comes
to mental health we have the chance
let's get this thing done
now just a few years ago alongside with
the mental health crisis we saw
and we're seeing
daily news stories we saw the data and
we saw that new hampshire we're seeing
drug related deaths continue to
skyrocket from 2013 to 2017 the numbers
were
going crazy looked like going up the
front side of cannon mountain i mean the
numbers were just unbelievable and every
day we kept hearing those stories
our drug related deaths in that time
period doubled
when i became governor i think we said
enough is enough and instead of just
pumping more money frankly into a
failing system with little
accountability we took the challenge
head-on and again we said we're going to
build a new system a system that
actually achieves results
so we have it up and running today it's
called the doorways
and it does it's a system that didn't
just focus on 28 days of treatment
goodbye good luck
that was literally how we treated a lot
of the individuals who are suffering
through this crisis
but the doorways
is an integrated system it takes all of
those wrap around services that are
critical for long the long-term success
not just a 28-day success but the
long-term success of that individual and
that family
treatment recovery transitional housing
recovery friendly workplaces harm
reduction prevention all of that is now
wrapped into a continuum
and we put it all across the state
now we have access to 24 7 services in
this area now just because you live up
in co-ops or grafton we're not asking
folks to drive 200 miles to get a
service that frankly should be in their
backyard we're delivering those services
when they want them
how they want them and where they are
and thanks to the doorway and frankly
the incredible men and women also that
are working in that system
to support it
in 2021 new hampshire became one of the
only states in america where overdose
deaths did not increase
in fact over the last two years
we've reduced drug overdose deaths by
more than 10 percent while the rest of
the country has gone up 50 percent we
are bucking the national trend
look we haven't won the battle we know
this
nearly 400 people still lost their lives
to drug overdose deaths last year we are
not we have not won the battle by far
but the tools and resources that we have
deployed citizens can rest assured again
that we're simply just leaving no stone
unturned we're challenging ourselves to
do things a little differently and we're
demanding that we get results from those
systems now we talk a lot about mental
health we're talking a lot about opioids
but a lot of folks lately are also
talking one of the big words of the
day's infrastructure
governor that you know great services is
important but i live in a rural
community what are you going to do about
broadband i live in a community
with contaminated groundwater my well is
contaminated right what are we doing for
the infrastructure of the state because
that making those investments ensures
that we're not just solving a problem
for the next five or ten but literally
the next hundred years potentially for
what might come
so during covet in 2020 we were one of
the only states to make broadband
investments this was a really amazing
process i didn't i wasn't even sure if
we could get it done but using some of
the cares act money we delivered new
high-speed broadband
to about 4 500 families all across the
state and we did it in just a couple
months and because of that model because
we were so aggressive about it back then
now that these new dollars are being
made available through arp and the
infrastructure
we are one of the we're going to be one
of the first states because we're just
kind of copying and duplicating the
model that we had that worked so
successfully we're now going to be one
of the first states to deliver
high-speed broadband to tens of
thousands of more individuals over the
next couple years a huge huge
opportunity
and we continue to make big investments
to address pfas contamination in our
water system look i was an environmental
engineer right this is what i did i used
to drill those wells and sample that
contaminated water it was chlorinated
solvents that was one of my specialties
and i can say without a doubt that the
pfas groundwater contamination issue
that we have in the state is one of the
biggest environmental concerns that the
state has ever seen
i see chuck over here i'm going to do it
on chuck a little bit
it takes leadership to really get this
stuff done
when i first became governor i don't
even think i was inaugurated yet i think
this is right
i think maybe it was in december
and
at the time senate president morse came
to me and started talking about this
concept they had about a fund and the
fact we could take some of the money we
had gotten from a large settlement and
create a fund and we knew that would
kind of just scratch the surface and we
said gee how many towns could we get to
and it was a lot there's a lot you can
do with a couple hundred million dollars
to be sure but as over time we've seen
the need grow and we didn't say well
that's just it we put a bunch of money
in there good luck goodbye and good luck
we continue to make those investments in
just the last year we made another 150
million dollar of investments with
senator morris's leadership using some
of the federal supports we have using
some of our local dollars and again
making sure
that this crisis that we do have for a
lot of families there are a lot of
families out there still drinking
bottled water all the time because they
don't have access
but we're not settling on that senator
morse is driving forward
hundreds of millions of dollars in new
investments we're taking that challenge
head on and again it's not something
that's going to solve it today but also
for the next 20 and 50 years so thank
you senator morris
[Applause]
you know people talk about inflation
this is another one i actually got a
call this morning someone said why are
you lowering why aren't you solving
inflation governor
look i get the sentiment we're all
feeling it right
especially low-income families inflation
is the worst tax you can possibly put
upon a low-income family
they have to put gas in their tank just
as much as anybody else
so do not address that at the national
level there's only so much we know we
can do at the state level but i think we
put some innovative stuff in there
but to not address that at the national
level to not address the fact that fuel
costs are skyrocketing and in a place
like new hampshire people have to heat
their homes
have you seen some of the fuel oil bills
coming to your constituents lately it's
out of control
is there any sense that washington is
addressing the fuel issue that is
addressing the inflationary pressures on
our system no
now that's where i think the new
hampshire stepped up and said we're
going to cut taxes we're going to take
financial burdens off of our citizens
we're going to do what we can to offset
those national pressures that are coming
we know that the increasing those costs
and when we see those costs skyrocketing
it hurts our job creators our families
seniors seniors on fixed incomes right
they have to feel that heating that oil
that inflationary pressure as much as
anybody else
so i think what we've seen over the past
year it reinforces a philosophy on
energy in particular that i try to
always bring to the table first and
foremost we have to prioritize our
ratepayers and we have to make sure our
policy decisions
don't
unduly overburden them
and when possible we want to strive to
make new hampshire solutions that are
innovative and also responsible
so
having a more of a methodical way of
addressing energy policy in new
hampshire over the past few years has
proven to be inc i think incredibly
successful
over the last five years i did i just
saw the statistic over the last five
years the increase in energy costs for
massachusetts
double that of new hampshire that's
pretty incredible let me say that a
different way if we had just done what
massachusetts did with all of their
projects saying yes to everything across
the table an extra hundred million
dollars of burden would have been placed
on our again our low income families our
senior citizens they would have to pay
another 100 million dollars just to turn
on the light switch
that's wrong
so we took a step back and we knew we
weren't going to go down a path blindly
we can be very we can be much smarter we
stepped up we did we established a
department of energy
you know one thing that i i noticed is
that
when i looked at historically what was
happening
every project that came across
individuals desks were just funded
right the lobbyists would get involved
the special interests would get involved
oh just fund it just fund it we don't
want to take the political hit
the political win is standing up for
your citizens who have to pay those
bills every single month right
and so we said we can still be smart
about how we do renewable energy we
fought hard to do solar panels and solar
projects but you know what let's put
them on the low-income families
locations first right maybe their inner
city locations maybe their mobile home
parks maybe their senior citizens homes
we all get the environmental benefit but
let let's let those who have the least
bill amount of
least amount of possibility to pay those
high burdens
let's let those be the first of the
trough to get the financial benefits
when we do that
it's just very strategic as opposed to
we're going to do a little bit of
everything everywhere
offshore wind i'm incredibly proud that
again we finally established this office
for offshore wind industry and
development because we can do it in a
very responsible way clean reliable
offshore wind will be a reality here in
new hampshire no doubt
you might not be able to see it it's
going to be way off the coast but i
guarantee you we're all going to get the
benefits of that and we didn't just run
that run through the door first right we
saw how some of these other projects are
playing out we saw how some of those
costs are being managed
and my point in all this is is just
saying
we're finding smarter ways to do things
net metering
right we had the net metering battle
going on in the legislature in our
office for a couple years
but last year we found a way to bring
folks together find a compromise move
forward on net metering with clean
energy
with more solar power and letting the
cities and towns actually dictate their
energy future for themselves a huge huge
win i'm seeing i see michael vos out
there senator avar a lot of folks really
came together to make that happen thank
you guys
you know a couple years ago i'm not sure
which speech it was i think i was i was
before the legislature i'm not sure
which which time but
one of the things that i said was that
you know those of us that are born here
in new hampshire we're lucky and those
that move here are smart
apparently there's a lot of really smart
people moving into new hampshire right
because we're seeing this real
population boom that we haven't seen in
a long long time
but they are families that are coming
here and businesses that are coming here
for a specific reason right they didn't
just throw a dart on them on a map and
say well maybe new hampshire will be
okay they're very strategically said
that's where i want to be and they're
coming out of california they're coming
out of nevada they're coming out of new
york in new jersey in michigan minnesota
but these are families that are looking
for low taxes they're looking for good
schools they're looking for a sense of
community they're looking for that
quality of life and living that we talk
about with the mountains and the lakes
and the rivers and the oceans
and when you look in when you look at
the opportunities that we provide
there's no place that people want to
want to be more in the northeast than
right here in new hampshire so that
presents opportunities and challenges to
be sure and so one of our biggest
challenges that we are seeing that we
talk about almost on a daily basis now
is the availability of housing for
working families
our state shortage of available housing
was further squeezed by the pandemic
everyone started pouring in
and so
we can just harp on the challenge or we
can say where's the opportunity right
where's the opportunity again to make
the right investments the right
regulatory changes invest in the
infrastructure not just for tomorrow but
really for the long term i created the
housing the council on housing stability
in november of 2020 and that council
really designed kind of a three-year
plan it aims to reduce homelessness and
really attack the homelessness issue
which we see rampant all across this
country but we have our issues here as
well we can't ignore that
it really aims to increase housing units
for working families by over thirteen
thousand units in the next three years
which sounds like a lot but it is
achievable is an achievable goal
that is within our grasp
so
i'll continue to ask the legislature i
know it got put on hold but we have sb
400 a bill that senator bradley hey jeff
how are you senator bradley really
champion sb 400 really creates some
regulatory flexibilities and some
incentives at the local level to really
move things forward because that's where
we see things stalling out but we know
that sb 400 just won't be enough
i've repeatedly asked the federal
government right we have this rental
relief money that comes in and mortgage
relief money that is coming in and i've
asked the federal government multiple
times can you give us some flexibility
those things might be super important
top priority in other parts of the
country it's important here to be sure
but let us take some of those funds that
are currently being unused and find ways
to create actual more housing right you
want to solve the housing crime in new
hampshire bricks and mort are creating
more they said no the federal government
won't give any more flexibility on any
of those funds
i'm not deterred i don't think anybody
should be turd frankly
so we know that we do have to make an
investment today we know that we can
move forward create more of that
workforce housing but just as important
do so in a way
this is the important part in a way that
really preserves who we are in our
communities what we're about whether
it's in the small towns or our largest
cities preserve everything we are as
granite staters and we have a shared
responsibility to our neighbors and to
our businesses that are relying on the
housing to get the workforce so that
they can keep growing here and taking
advantage of all the opportunity that
we're creating for them
this is the way we do it in new
hampshire
now today because we've had so much
financial success
i'm proposing the invest nh housing
incentive fund
a historic 100 million dollar fund using
our dollars to rebuild and expand
housing for our next generation so it's
a multi-tiered approach
let me walk you through it
first step
my proposal will invest 60 million
dollars in flexible grants to match
investments for multi-family housing
projects already ready already to ready
to move and getting in into the building
stages
and one of the issues that we know we
have is slow or uncertain permitting at
the local level that happens a lot so i
want to incentivize towns right not with
the stick we do things in new hampshire
with the carrot we want to incentivize
them
so with this plan i'm calling for a 30
million dollar commitment to reward
municipalities that can approve permits
within six months of application those
grants will be made directly to the
towns to offset the costs that they may
see and increase their ability to invest
locally
third
i want to create this is a little bit of
interesting one something i heard all
across the state a five million dollar
demolition fund
we found all these projects across the
state that weren't moving forward
because we had dilapidated housing often
from the 20s or 30s or 40s the cost to
remove that housing or do the
environmental cleanup for those projects
was too much so the developer wouldn't
do it the town wouldn't do it so they
wanted the town or city might want new
housing to move in
but you had this dilapidated housing
that was frankly an environmental
problem a plight it lowered property
values and inhibited that development
growth that we want to see so a 5
million demolition grant fund for those
communities to help match some of the
costs and offset some of the costs that
they might have to really clear away for
new sustainable well-designed well-built
housing and finally i want to invest
directly into the cities and towns by
providing five million dollars in
planning grants and zoning grants so
many towns are looking for the
assistance to update their planning and
zoning laws we have towns that haven't
changed zoning and planning laws in 40
years here right they have to bring in a
consultant it might take some cost they
don't have that money for whatever
reason so let's create a fund again to
help them at the local level move their
process a little faster a little further
along that brings more again attracts
more investment brings more developers
in and ultimately gets it done these
investments are critical they are
absolutely critical in ensuring that new
hampshire continues to be the number one
destination in new england the housing
is for workers they are for families
they're for those who contribute to our
community they go to our schools they
boom our economy and so the data is very
clear housing creates regional
stabilities for families and businesses
and that's a win that i'm hoping the
legislature can help us deliver on
so back in 2020
new hampshire we took an aggressive
approach i think in the right approach
in tackling issues surrounding law
enforcement accountability
our correctional reforms modernizing our
detention systems
we ensure that law enforcement work in
conjunction with community leaders to
develop our commission on law
enforcement accountability we call it
lee act
new hampshire law enforcement remains
the gold standard across the country
they it really does from the very local
level in the small towns working
seamlessly with the state police with
our federal partners
in fact our system is so good working so
seamlessly not just building up fiefdoms
but working together as a team
that we are out teaching other states
how to do it we're working across the
borders in maine and vermont and
massachusetts right
so knowing that we were able to do that
gave us the opportunity to really take
on some of the challenges and do it
together right and do it in a very
comprehensive way
the leak commission that we put together
was able to move forward on a lot of the
initiatives and a lot of the the ideas
that they had some were at police
standard in training some happened right
here in the legislature some we could do
with executive order some required
funding some were as simple as you know
body cams for our cops and somewhere
more advanced is how we're going to
train and teach and work with law
enforcement in a seamless way right
state local and federal
but we also looked very aggressively and
this legislature deserves a lot of
credit looked very aggressively
at our correction system designed for
for youth for our kids
after years of inaction
we brought from the shadows the horrific
cases of abuse that occurred at new
hampshire's youth detention facility in
manchester
the attorney general's office continues
the comprehensive criminal investigation
into these these allegations and while
the abuse may occur many years or even
decades ago
i think i speak for everyone in here
when i say that we are not going to stop
until we've brought all those
perpetrators to justice and to that end
to that end working with the attorney
general i know he's brought to this
legislature a proposal to set a hundred
million dollar settlement fund for
compensating these victims it's the
sensible thing to do it's the right
thing to do i hope you'll support me in
creating the fund so we can bring
closure to what has been an incredible
pain incredibly painful process we got
to move the current group of kids
right we can't forget we still have kids
in that facility today
and again we got to make sure that we're
providing not just the security around
those children but a model that works
for them a 21st century thinking model
and so bringing those group of kids to
more of a treatment focused model
and then frankly bulldoze that
i won't use a swear word
bulldoze that darn building to the
ground once and for all in the city of
manchester
that's the opportunity i see community
based services treatment based services
saying we're going to move beyond a
failed system of the past we're going to
write what we need to write and we're
designing for the future in a way that
can be more sustainable and create a
better product for all of us
so despite our ranking as the number one
state in public safety in the united
states we obviously know that there is
still a lot more to do to keep
communities safe that's always a
challenge that we need to take on i was
very grateful i
saw just yesterday the senate passed sb
294 that will ensure violent criminals
don't automatically walk free on bail
i mean who doesn't want to who wants to
see a violent criminal walk free on bail
i'm not sure how everyone in this room
isn't standing up for that frankly
it's critical in protecting victims of
domestic violence attackers should be
able just to walk right out and prey on
their victims once again and this
legislature is standing up and doing
something about it so at a time when law
enforcement across the country they are
faced with unspeakable danger we have to
continue and stand up for a system that
prioritizes safe communities above all
else with that gold standard for public
safety sb 294 will make us safer do
whatever you can get that bill to my
desk so we can get it done thank you
guys
so i'd like to close
i know it was longer than y'all thought
longer than i thought i apologize a lot
of good stuff i'm excited but i want to
close with a really exciting opportunity
and a project
um
it's honestly the last project we're
going to do but the last one i'll i'll
kind of push here because i think it's
it's a incredible opportunity one area
that i think we are all passionate about
uh is supporting our veterans right and
our active military service members we
do a great job of that here in new
hampshire can always do more to be sure
but we we always make sure that that is
on the front of our mindset this past
year we opened a new state-of-the-art uh
homeless facilities uh for our veterans
for struggling veterans we know we can
do more um i want to talk about a
project that i think thinks a little
bigger a little broader a little more
encompassing and a little more 21st
century in terms of what our obligation
our responsibility is to deliver for
those individuals those heroes that
stand up for the united states of
america
a lot of new hampshire citizens have
answered that call to service it's a
proud legacy in our state
uh something that we're all eternally
grateful for but over the past few
months i've been working with attendant
general david mikulitis
led to some folks in legislative
leadership um
some folks with our veterans support
groups around the state on a proposal
that takes advantage of an opportunity
and a partnership with easter seals a
great non-profit group that does a lot
of different things here in new
hampshire this 21 million dollar
initiative will create a you very unique
all-encompassing veterans campus
and so the veterans campus is being
proposed for a site up in franklin new
hampshire it's designed to really
integrate veterans
active military their families a campus
that includes housing support services a
retreat center an integration of care
coordination therapeutic and
recreational services all designed by
veterans and military personnel for
veterans and military personnel
and i think that with this project
moving forward like never before new
hampshire is going to be that gold
standard i keep using that term but that
gold standard as we should be for those
who have stood up for us uh so bravely
across this country but designing a
campus that integrates all of these
amazing services because at the end of
the day it's about the health and
wellness of american heroes
we're going to push out a lot of more
details and information it's a project
that's moving along very aggressively
and i hope the legislature will find a
way to support it
so
in closing
we have had a lot of success over the
last year there's no doubt about it even
with all the challenges we face and a
lot more opportunity ahead of us let's
not take any of our progress for granted
as they say we don't just rest on our
laurels of success you got to keep
driving forward and keep putting new
ideas on the table
now too often we see it on the national
level especially we see folks really in
this country fighting in the extremes we
see idle ideological differences that
can bring great ideas to a screeching
halt and sometimes it's all over some
political turf battle more than anything
we can't let that happen here in new
hampshire as a state we're moving full
speed ahead but we can't get bogged down
or disrupted by those extremes and we
have to have the courage to reject a lot
of those notions
the citizens of this state did not hire
us just to be political ideologues they
hired us to do a job they hired us to
get results
and frankly if you're here to get
attention
over the fight that frankly gets us
nowhere i don't think any of us have any
patience for that
and i have
never and i will never let our process
and our opportunity
be hijacked by radical radical elements
on either side of the aisle this is new
hampshire
i know you see it on the on the news all
the time that happens in washington
every day i don't see anybody trying to
stand up and really stop it here in new
hampshire
we work hard to keep it from holding us
back
let's not let social media dictate our
priorities or our sentiments
it's not really real i think a lot of us
know that let's not fixate on cable news
as opposed
[Applause]
[Music]
so
without objection we're going to adjourn
from the governor's address and take a
brief recess
members take your seats please
um members take your seats please
representative tucker would you please
come up front representative tucker
representative tucker
that's scary
oh
hey watch out for the live mic
so
probably gone
now
oh
so
the house will now attend to the
continuation of the regular calendar
beginning with house bill
fm from the committee on executive
department's administration
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
house bill 1535 fn
enact
relative to cost delivering adjustments
for retirees in the state retirement
system having considered the same report
the same with the following amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment is in carol
mcguire for the committee
the amendment is zero five five one age
printed in house record six page sixty
nine are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the motion be
before us now
is the ought to pass as amended on house
bill 1535 fn are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
and it's referr it is referred to
finance
representative shapiro andrus moffat
mcdonald
and gordon declared a conflict of
interest and did not participate in the
vote
majority of the committee on executive
departments and administration to which
was referred house bill 1587 fna an act
relative to determination of average
final compensation
under the retirement system and making
an appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass senator tom one zero for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator santo
naso for the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
santonosto
oh i'm sorry
uh
just a second chair recognizes
representative pearson
mike
c1 microphones
testing thank you
thank you mr speaker thank you
colleagues
it's been an interesting day
the the governor mentioned and talked
about the
prison system i want to touch on that a
little bit we have a crisis in new
hampshire right now
that a lot of people are not aware of at
this point in time only 50 percent 50
percent of the positions in the state
prison system are staffed
we're using national guard troops
right now
in our prison in the state of new
hampshire
and as a result of that
we've had some interesting things occur
we heard testimony in committee from a
female corrections officer who has been
forced in this past year to work 100
hour weeks on mandatory overtime
she's worked for the state for quite a
long time
she's had enough so she went over and
talked to the retirement system
and the retirement system said
thank you for working 100 hour work
weeks
this past year but none of that's gonna
count
she was taken aback as most of you would
think you would be as you paid in from
your paycheck
over that time period
to then have the retirement system say
sorry
that year that you sacrifice doesn't
count
and what we learned in committee in
consultation with the retirement system
was that in fact money was being taken
from her paycheck based on her income
and not counting towards her pension
calculation but going into the general
re retirement fund
i tell you this if money is taken from
someone's paycheck and placed in any
sort of a general type fund that is an
income tax
by its very definition
nowhere in the private sector does an
investment require you to pay for five
years
and then not count your contributions
to your investment portfolio
[Music]
so i ask you colleagues
to support health bill 1587 and remove
the first responder income tax
loophole in our statute thank you mr
speaker
chair recognized representative
knoxville for uh
speaking against the committee report
mr speaker mr speaker c3 i had a
question for the previous speaker
does the member yield to a question
remember does not yield
you you may begin representative
oh
uh wait a minute microphone d1
mr speaker okay
thank you thank you mr speaker
representative santo nostasso uh mr
speaker currently in statute final
compensation calculation for all new
hampshire retirees is the same
this bill unfairly increases the final
compensation just for group two retirees
and leaves group one the way it is this
is because the cost group to include
group one would be too expensive
instead of increasing retirement
benefits for one class of retirees we
should work on a solution that is fair
to both
if we pass this bill the problem will
return as group one retirees demand the
same benefit
since the cost is too high the
legislator will be unable to give them
the same benefit putting us in a corner
to explain why group 1 doesn't deserve
the same calculation or walk back the
benefit to group 2.
the retirement system is already dealing
with a six billion dollar unfunded
liability if we're going to use the
general fund for retirement system we
should consider stopping the bleeding
before adding this additional ongoing
liability
this bill leaves the open question on
the possibility of gaming the retirement
system sometimes to refer to as pension
spiking
this would be some sort of scheme where
an employee gains his wages in such a
way that earns him a retirement greater
than intended
lastly to suggest we need this nuanced
change in the way the retirement benefit
is calculated to retain and recruit
public workers is ridiculous the labor
shortage is a universal problem over the
entire economy regardless of what the
retirement benefit provided if it was
the case that the labor shortage was
correlated with retirement package then
maybe this argument would be sound
so i'm asking to vote no on house bill
1587 and mr speaker i asked for a
division vote
does the member yield a question
ah no question
number does not yield
chair recognizes representative lanzaro
thank you mr speaker
at d2
horizon support of 1587.
fire stations police stations
correctional facilities across new
hampshire are suffering from staffing
shortages
this impacts our public safety our
communities are now relying on fewer
people to do these jobs
leading to staggering amounts of forced
overtime the brave men and women
protecting our state are already
contributing over 11 and a half percent
in order to fund their pension
however when you calculate their
contributions
their highest five years of compensation
over bases excluded
this means that the employee is not
working
more hours in an attempt to make up what
was changing new hampshire retirement
system in 2011
but their retirement calculation is not
a true representation of what they've
paid into the system
this is one of the many issues currently
impacting recruitment and retention
across the state new hampshire is losing
more first responders than gating thank
you mr speaker
this is going to be a division vote
members will take their seats
roll call has been requested
it is sufficiently seconded
roll call
so
a question for the
speaker what's the reason to memorize
a question about the uh process for
passing this bill
if
so this is a two committee bill it's
going to go on to finance after this if
members might support the bill but have
concerns about the cost
does the finance committee have the
power to reduce the total cost amount on
this bill
okay all right yeah i couldn't hear your
representative the finance committee
will obviously have deliberations on
this bill that if it passes that's where
it will go
all right thank you
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
senators for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this favors one class of
retiree over another
and if i know that we are creating an
opportunity for pension spiking
and if i know this adds a larger
liability to the retirement system
and if i know the labor is a universal
problem and not just isolated public
workers then would i press the red
button so another motion could be made
chair recognizes representative pratt
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know
no private
if i know no private investment fund
would take your money for five years and
tell you it doesn't count
if i know taking money based on income
at the rate 11.55 to 11.8 and not apply
it towards the final income calculation
is an income tax
and if i no further
no as a past fire standards and training
commissioner of 18 years
the occupations like fire police and
corrections have seen a dramatic
decrease in applications in the last
several years
and if i believe we need to do
everything within reason to make sure
the citizens of the state receive
the law enforcement protection the fire
protection
and the ems services that are needed
will i now press the green button to
send this to finance
thank
you question is on the majority report
about to pass
on house bill 1587. this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you press the
green button if you're approached you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative burudi
representative belanger
representative kaplan
representative de palma
representative dotsy
representative grassy
representative kenny representative
langley
representative suffocatus
representative van
it was dotsy not datsy sorry
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
else will tend to the state of the vote
232 voting a 113 voting aid the
committee report is a doctor
and as under the house rules it is
referred to the committee on finance
senator vandrust declared a conflict of
interest and did not participate
majority of the committee on executive
departments and administration to which
was referred host bill 1590 fn
act relative to municipalities
withdrawing from the state retirement
system having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that as in expedient to
legislate president of steve pearson for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree when the majority report with the
recommendation of the bill be referred
for interim study representative matthew
santana for the minority of the
committee
the question before us now is the
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
division
the question before us
is inexpedient to legislate on house
bill 1590 fn local this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your approach will press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
perfect
[Music]
representative allegro
representative bouchard
representative kretion
representative hill
representative hobson
representative moran
representative litchfield thank you
representative schuett
representative sheehan
representative salloway
representative yokela
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend the city of the vote
287 voting gay
57 voting a committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 13 1536 fn
act relative to expanding medicaid to
include
certain postpartum health care services
have been considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
representative erica leon for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment sent joe shapiro for
the minority of the committee mr speaker
for what member does the what reason
does a member rise to make a motion
stage of motion to table
the motion before us is a proper motion
the motion to table has been
accepted um
the motion to table are you ready for
the question
division has been requested
members will take their seats
division
the motion before us is is a tabling
motion on house bill 1536
this is going to be a division vote the
chair recognizes representative weather
weber for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you thank you mr speaker
if i know
that maternal health
and the health of our very youngest
citizens
is an investment that will repay itself
many times over
would i now vote red on the tabling
motions so we may debate the bill thank
you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative layon
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i knew that states like new hampshire
who expanded medicaid
have
six percent fewer beds today
and states that did not adopt it have
more beds
and if i know that today one of our
biggest crises is the number of hospital
beds we have for covet and non-covet
patients
and further if i knew
that
right now we cannot take anybody off
of our medicaid roles for income
eligibility
because of those current rules would i
know that this is something that can
wait into a later date when we know the
impact of our hospital system and
therefore press the green button to
table this bill
the question before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1536
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative acton
representative boards
representative dostie
representative kolansky
representative lachman
to represent moran
representative sheehan
representative wilhelm
representative ankerberg
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
183 voting yeah 161 voting a committee
report is adopted
i was i correct myself the motion to lay
on the table is adopted
majority committee on health and human
services in elderly phase 2 which was
referred house bill 1578 fn and act
relative to including certain children
pregnant people in medicaid and
children's health
insurance program having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved it is inexpedient to
legislate as an adventist acting for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
represent joe shapiro for the minority
of committee mr what reason does a
member rise to make a motion stage of
motion to table
emotion is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table
house bill 1578 fn of the division has
been requested members will take their
seats
division
she's down to the pi
oh it's true
the question before us is the tabling
motion for house bill 1578.
the chair recognizes representative
weber for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if we care about promoting
the health
of both mothers and their unborn
children in this state
and if we know
that preventative services
and adequate health care
is an investment that
saves us money and reduces the use of
critical emergency services and
in-hospital beds long term
and if we know that we ought to extend
these benefits
to the very newest of our citizens would
i now vote red on the tabling motion
chair recognizes the representative
layout for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker
if i knew that refugees already have
access to medicaid coverage
and if i knew that while this bill
states that it is for legal immigrants
testimony in committee spoke almost
exclusively to the need of those who
came into compliance with the law
only after being detained for their
status
and if i knew that states who have
extended this generosity on the backs of
their taxpayers are facing insolvency
and therefore are losing the ability to
help anyone would i then press the green
button to table this bill
the motion before us is a tabling motion
and house bill 1578. this is the
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative abel
representative chase
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
household 10 to the state of the vote
187 voting yay 161 voting nay the motion
to table
is adopted
majority committee on health and human
services and elderly affairs to which
was referred house bill 1604 fn
act including state medical facilities
in the statute providing medical freedom
and immunizations having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator leah cushman from the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpediential legislate senator jerry
conrad for the minority of the committee
the amendment is zero five five four h
printed in house record six page eighty
one are you ready for the question on
the adoption of the amendment
for what member reason does the member
rise i had signed up to speak against
the amendment
okay
chair chair recognizes representative
kenner
the medical freedom from immunization
statute which prohibited vaccine
mandates
exempted the status from statute the
county nursing homes the new hampshire
state hospital or any other medical
facility operated by the state of new
hampshire or any political subdivision
thereof and this would allow them to
mandate vaccinations for health care
workers for the protection of their
patients and residents if needed
hb 1604 would repeal that exemption
the amendment limits the exemption to
facilities which are subject to the
centers of medicaid and medicare
services covet 19 vaccination mandate
for health care facilities which receive
medicare or medicaid funds in order to
not conflict with that cms mandate
now
that would appear to solve a conflict
but it really doesn't because the
amendment also mandates that such
facilities shall automatically
upon request
grant an exemption for vaccination to
any person who simply requests an
exemption for medical religious or
conscientious objection reasons without
any documentation as to the medical
reason the religious basis or the
conscientious objection
this is in conflict with the rules
promulgated by cms with regard to the
covet 19 vaccination mandate which
requires documentation of the medical
reason
for the medical exemption
signed by a licensed practitioner
documentation of religious exemptions
and does not
allow conscientious objection as an
exemption
this would place our facilities out of
compliance with the cms mandate and at
risk of civil penalties
loss of reimbursement for medicare and
medicaid patients and ultimately
termination from the medicare and
medicaid programs
remember medicaid pays the bill for
two-thirds of our nursing home residents
and also since compliance with federal
regulation is required for accreditation
facilities lack of compliance with the
mandate will also lead to loss of
accreditation and therefore risk of
losing payment
from private insurers as well
the state of new hampshire would then
need to backfill that revenue loss in
order to keep those facilities running
starting with at least the 200 million
dollars which annually which is the
federal share of medicaid funding for
long-term care in new hampshire alone
now the majority has claimed that cms
will not stop the reimbursement as it
has not happened in other states who
have put similar laws in place
but that is not any guarantee as the
mandate is new and enforcement actions
have not commenced yet
vaccination mandates in the health care
setting are crucial and they are common
even though transmission can still occur
with a breakthrough coveted infection
vaccinated workers will still have a far
lower rate of infection so the risk of
transmission to a patient on the
aggregate at the population level
will be diminished with vaccination
and since hospitals and long-term care
facilities care for vulnerable
individuals they must do everything they
can to maintain safety and that includes
a reasonable expectation
of a patient or a resident in a nursing
home from the health care from
unnecessary exposure to an infectious
respiratory disease from the health care
worker who cares for them
the us supreme court ruling on january
13 2022 upheld the cms mandate for
vaccination of health care workers
staying the lower court injunction
the majority of the committee discounts
this as quote just to stay end quote but
that text to the supreme court decision
makes it clear
that they support the cms vaccine
mandate saying quote we accordingly
conclude that the secretary did not
exceed his statutory authority in
requiring that in order to remain
eligible for medicare and medicaid
dollars the facilities covered by the
interim rule must ensure that their
employees be vaccinated against covet 19
end quote
that makes it clear that if the lower
court decision ultimately makes it to
the supreme court on appeal that they
will uphold the mandate and to date no
appeal of the lower court injunction has
been filed in summary
both the bill has introduced and the
amendment placed us out of compliance
with the cms vaccination mandate with
significant consequences so i would ask
you to vote no that's the red button on
the amendment to hb60 1604 and mr
speaker i ask for a division vote thank
you
chair recognizes representative leon
speak against to speak in favor of the
amendment
thank you mr speaker
right now
glencliff home our new hampshire
hospital and our nursing homes are
functioning with their current staff not
whom of not not all of whom have
complied with the vaccine mandates today
we heard testimony of one facility
where only 87
of the health care staff
had confirmed vaccination status
so we may be losing 13
of the staff if we don't provide
an opportunity
to
meet
and grant these exemptions
you might question how the safety has
been if there's 13 percent of the
employees who either are unvaccinated or
unwilling to disclose their status
glencliff home went over a year without
a case of covet
our nursing homes county nursing homes
are doing a phenomenal job
the system is working well
and providing these exemptions will
allow our health care system to continue
to function well
now we have the question about the right
of conscience
when we look to our constitution in
article four part one
it talks about those rights that are
unalienable which cannot be traded away
or given away because there is no
fair trade for those rights
and among those is the right of
conscience
we speak to our religious freedom in the
constitution in article five of part one
we may or may not know that that freedom
to practice religion is based upon one's
own conscience and reason
in new hampshire
the right of religion includes the right
of conscience i believe that that is a
very strong case
that this is within
our rights and our duties to protect our
staff
from having to make a choice that they
may not be comfortable doing and to
protect our patients by keeping staffing
levels appropriate
we have a shortage
this is a solution
i ask for you to vote in favor of this
amendment and press the green button
this will be a division vote
on the amendment
division
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the question before us is the amendment
to house bill
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
kenner for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know
that the united states supreme court has
already rendered an opinion
that clearly supports the cms mandate
requiring vaccination of health care
workers and institutions which receive
reimbursement from medicaid and medicare
and if i know that hb1604 is amended
would place the state of new hampshire
in conflict with the rules of the cms
mandate
and if i also know
that the healthcare workforce shortage
has been present for a number of years
prior to covet 19
and that health care facilities which
have imposed vaccine mandates have had
nearly complete compliance
rather than mass resignation
and if i know that lack of compliance
with this mandate may lead to loss of
accreditation of our institutions loss
of medicare and medicaid reimbursement
leading to the need for state of new
hampshire to backfill hundreds of
million dollars in funding to keep our
nursing homes and hospitals open
would i then vote no with the red button
on the
amendment so that another
so that we can move forward with this
bill
chair recognizes representative leon
thank you mister parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i understood 87
not to be
[Music]
near complete
and if i understood that despite
media reports the supreme court did not
make a ruling
it gave an opinion which has far less
weight and suggests that this is still
in play
and if i knew that state laws
will have a significant role
in how exemptions are handled going
forward
would i then press the green button to
adopt the committee amendment
question before us is the
amendment on 1604
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative abramson
representative heir
representative amanda bolden
representative dostie
representative hunt
representative ham
i got you
if all members president an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
i haven't voted
house will be in order
as it is my privilege as speaker to
break the tie i vote yay
the vote is 174-173
the committee amendment is adopted
the question now before us is on the
house bill 1604 majority report about to
pass as amended
the chair recognizes representative
kenner for
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker as i already noted
hb 1604 is an amendment amended would
place our facilities out of compliance
with the cms covet 19 vaccination
mandate for health care workers which
work in facilities that receive medicare
or medicaid funds
and at risk of civil penalties loss of
reimbursement for medicare and medicaid
patients and ultimately termination from
the medicare and medicaid programs
we have seen that when
vaccination mandates were placed in
various places such as at dartmouth that
the vaccination rate skyrocketed we did
not see mass resignation
lack of compliance with the cms mandate
will lead to loss of accreditation to
facilities as well and therefore the
risk of losing payment from private
insurers as well
this loss of reimbursement is going to
require the state of new hampshire to
backfill hundreds of millions of dollars
in funding to keep our hospitals and
nursing homes open are we really
prepared to do that
vaccination mandates in the healthcare
setting are crucial common and
responsible
since hospitals and long-term care
facilities care for vulnerable
individuals
they must do everything they can to
maintain safety
and that includes a reasonable
expectation of a patient or resident not
to face
unnecessary exposure to an infectious
respiratory disease from the health care
worker who is caring for them
the u.s supreme court has upheld the cms
mandate for vaccination of health care
workers stay in that lower court
decision and again the text of the
supreme court decision makes it clear
they support the cms mandate
we would be
out of compliance with that at our peril
so please vote no with the red button on
the motion of ought to pass with
amendment so that another motion
can be made and a request a division
vote please thank you
remember yielded questions
in the interest of time no remember does
not yield
the chair recognizes representative
cushman
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
hb
1604 repeals an exception in the medical
freedom and immunizations act that was
added during the committee of conference
last year and restores the law to the
version that was passed by this body and
the other chamber with one distinction
which was necessary to allow compliance
with the federal cms covid vaccine
mandate
you may have heard from lobbyists that
if this bill is passed it would result
in the loss of medicare and medicaid
funds and certification for our state
medical facilities
the truth is this bill is amended allows
for near perfect compliance with cms
survey requirements allowing for medical
and religious exemptions
a third exemption the right of
conscience exemption is not delineated
in the cms rule however it is a right
guaranteed in part 1 article 4 of the
new hampshire state constitution and the
state of new hampshire cannot be
permitted to violate its own
constitution by not permitting such an
exemption
other states such as florida and
arkansas have passed and implemented
laws that require additional exemptions
than what is expressly permitted in the
cms rule and have had no issues of loss
of funding for their facilities and
providers
their surveying agencies have simply
informed cms of the law and have
continued conducting their surveys and
issuing certification
cms made no indication that they would
be pulling funding denying reimbursement
or in any way penalizing those states
the supreme court upheld the authority
of cms to issue a covet vaccine mandate
but only in part sending the case back
to a lower court with the opinion that
adjustments need to be made surrounding
exemptions for employees
the state of florida and the national
association for health facilities survey
agencies which represents agencies
across the country that perform these
surveys
expect forthcoming adjustments in the
cms rule to allow for articulation with
the conflicting state laws
as these conflicting laws with
additional exemptions such as for
natural immunity right of conscience and
others are expected to increase this
year across the nation
at the end of the day cms exists to
provide payment for health care costs
for the most needy and slight variations
and exemptions for coveted mandates will
not result in denial of payment for
services to these people
this bill will be going to finance if
passed by this body today
the bill only applies to those
facilities that are owned by the state
of new hampshire and its political
subdivisions not private businesses
the attorney general of new hampshire
has ruled that the medical freedom and
immunizations act that this bill affects
only applies to covet 19 vaccinations
and nothing in this bill prohibits or
impedes the ability of these facilities
to employ mitigation strategies such as
screenings testing and ppe policies for
employees
there was already a health care
workforce shortage in our county nursing
homes before the cms rule and it has
only worsened since then the county
nursing homes are constantly running
short on staff
all american citizens including medical
professionals already have a right to
accommodations for medical issues under
the americans with disabilities act and
for religious beliefs under the civil
rights act of 1964.
unfortunately for healthcare workers
employers have changed the process from
one of checking a box and signing a form
for exemption as was typically done for
flu shots to one that amounts to be a
degrading and intrusive exchange that at
times demands years of medical history
of an employee including medical records
or a religious inquisition where a
representative from hr makes arbitrary
and discriminatory judgments on the
validity of a person's religion
it is nearly impossible to get a medical
exemption because doctors fear
punishment from regulatory boards for
writing them
many companies are just outright denying
all exemptions against federal law this
is illegal but most people do not have
the ability or finances to sue for their
rights
this bill ensures that that can no
longer happen in our state
medical facilities an employee simply
submits a simple statement requesting an
exemption
as the risks and poor effectiveness of
covet 19 vaccines become clearer and the
harm that mandates create is brought
into focus
other countries like the united kingdom
have started to eliminate their mandates
for healthcare workers the uk cited low
vaccine efficacy against omicron variant
and a critical health health care worker
shortage in their decision to drop their
mandate
how does it make sense that some nursing
homes in new hampshire are permitting
positively tested nurses and other staff
to work but not on vaccinated staff
in healthcare we have the right of
bodily autonomy it's the nurse's job to
ensure self-determination for patients
and it needs to be protected for
everyone including
how they still have their right of
health conscience and beliefs to
consider when making personal medical
decisions that right must be preserved
for health care workers as well when it
comes to staffing shortages the ones who
suffer the most when there are not
enough workers in the facility are the
patients
after patients it's the remaining staff
who suffer we need to prevent burnout
and moral distress for our health care
workers the state of new hampshire needs
to set the standard and say that it's
unethical and unconstitutional to deny
skilled competent medical professionals
employment and to deny patients the
staff to take care of them please
support this bill and i request a roll
call mr speaker
a division
house will be in order
there has been a request for roll calls
that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
thank you
the motion before us
on house bill 1604 is the majority
report about to pass as amended this is
a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
kenner for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the united states supreme
court has already rendered an opinion
that it clearly
supports the cms mandate requiring
vaccination of health care workers
in institutions which receive
reimbursement from medicare and medicaid
and if i know that hb1604 is amended
would place the state of new hampshire
in conflict with the rules of the cms
vaccine mandate
and if i know the lack of compliance
with this mandate may lead to loss of
accreditation of our institutions and
loss of medicare and medicaid
reimbursements leading to the need for
the state of new hampshire to backfill
hundreds of millions of dollars in
funding to keep our hospitals and
nursing homes open
and if i know also that it is so soon
after the mandate that of course payment
has not been withheld in other states as
there are steps in enforcement that
occur before that and if we make
assumptions about cms revising their
rules we do that at our peril
and if i know that the healthcare
workforce shortage predated the mandate
would i then vote no using that nice red
button on the otpa motion so that
another motion can be brought forth
thank you
chair recognize representative gay for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know that our overworked and
understaffed health care workers
are sincerely concerned for their
patients
and take great care to follow rules of
safety
and if i know that facilities impacted
by this bill
currently only have 87
compliance
and still have maintained a high level
of safety
and if i know that the legally
authorized exemptions
are supported by our new hampshire
constitution's
declaration of the unalienable right of
conscience
then wouldn't i press the green button
to pass this bill that will allow these
facilities to keep operating safely as
they are
question before us on house bill 1604 is
the majority report about to pass it as
amended this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button roaring stations
are open for 30 seconds
representative delemus
representative amanda bolden
representative chase
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
176 voting yay 174 voting nay the
committee report is adopted
and by rules of the house it is sent to
finance
please stay in their seats
all right
almost everybody has got their lunch
only a few don't if you don't have it
stay in your seats
we have one
lunchtime announcement
and
let's get back here at one o'clock
is in a breed
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
my
co-sponsors for coming up and standing
here with me
just a quick update
ballots polling is still open out there
on chocolate voting please come out and
rank your favorite chocolate there's
plenty of write-in options as well
polling will be open until 3 p.m today
and then tomorrow you all will get an
email showing you exactly
how it has turned out
um
and i will say that the acting secretary
of state david scanlon has also
participated in the election thank you
we are in recess to one o'clock
all right
[Music]
members take your seats
this is your two minute warning
oh
one minute
so
before we get on to the
next bill
in our calendar
i want everybody
to take about
a little bit of time and wish
jb
happy birthday
today's his birthday
[Applause]
i won't tell you his age
majority of committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred hb 1609 fn
an act relative to the scope of the
fetal protection act having considered
the same report the same the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator mark pearson for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendations the bill ought to pass
senator jerry connect from the minority
of the committee
the debate is going to be on the
amendment which is 0 0 48 h
printing and house record 6 pages 82-83
chair recognizes representative kenner
thank you mr speaker
i rise today
by the way i'm sorry we are speaking the
amendment at this point correct sir
mr speaker we are doing the amendment at
this point correct yep yes thank you
this is on the amendment yes yes i rise
today to speak against the committee
amendment to hb1609
1609 has introduced correct some of the
most troublesome provisions of the fetal
life protection act an act which
legislated the practice of medicine
regarding pregnancy termination after 24
weeks of gestational age
hb1609 as introduced would add
exceptions not present in current law
for rape incest and for the presence of
severe fetal anomalies which are
incompatible with life and remove the
unnecessary ultrasound mandate
if amended by the majority amendment it
would only remove the mandate for an
ultrasound before an abortion if the
fetal age is less than 24 weeks
but we need to pass this as introduced
termination of pregnancy after 24 weeks
your gestational age is a very rare
medical procedure usually done
in major medical procedures as centers
and nearly exclusively because of the
discovery of a severe fetal anomaly
which is incompatible with survival of
the infant or when the pregnancy results
in a severe risk to the mother's health
fetal anomalies may be discovered before
24 weeks but the severity may not be
apparent until later and some people may
not even have prenatal care before 24
weeks given our underinsured and
uninsured patients
now it's devastating for a mother and
father to be confronted with a severe
fetal anomaly that's not compatible with
survival
and accepted medical choices available
to parents are either termination of the
pregnancy
or to carry to term
and provide comfort care till the baby
dies
this difficult decision should be made
by the parents
and the provider
not legislators
by prohibiting the choice of termination
the fetal life protection act forces the
mother to carry the pregnancy to term
go through labor and delivery
only to deliver a stillborn baby or
watch their baby die
the majority report claims that abortion
after rape is not an issue
did another one go down
okay
is not an issue
as the woman has offered emergency
contraception often called the morning
after pill
but that is not true
in the case of rape or incest a woman
may be too traumatized to seek care in
time to use emergency contraception
which must be done within just a couple
of days to be effective and a survivor
of incest may not be able to even access
health care for termination due to being
controlled by the abuser or may not even
be aware
of being pregnant until 24 weeks
particularly if they're a child
only 20 states require the provision of
emergency contraception services and in
new hampshire ews are not required to
provide information about emergency
contraception or to dispense it upon
request
only 17 percent of women who are raped
undergo a medical exam after assault and
fewer than 40 percent of emergency rooms
provide emergency contraception or even
inform women
seeking care after assault that such
treatment is available
given that there are an estimated 25 000
rape related pregnancies per year in the
u.s
it is a problem
and the majority report also noted
anecdotes about false positive diagnoses
of severe fatal fetal anomalies
while the currently available new
chromosomal deletion screening blood
tests
are being used a great deal and do have
a notoriously high positive rate false
positive rate women facing this
difficult decision are referred to
highly specialized centers before
termination where more accurate
confirmatory diagnostic methods and
counseling will be used
in summary the majority amendment will
remove the important exceptions for rape
incest in fatal fetal anomaly leaving
only a revision of the ultrasound
mandate so please press the red button
to vote no on this amendment so that the
original bill which is far better can be
passed
and i do request a division vote mr
speaker thank you very much
does the member yield the questions
for the interest of time no please thank
you member does not yield
chair recognizes representative pierce
mark pearson
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker on january one of this year
new hampshire began to protect fetal
life after 24 weeks
i and i'm sure many of my colleagues saw
that television spot repeated many times
last fall
featuring a kindly woman physician
stating that what we just passed was the
strictest prohibition on abortion ever
enacted in new hampshire
that statement mr speaker i would
suggest was disingenuous
of course it had to be the strictest
prohibition because today it's the only
prohibition
i could similarly
say that what we passed into law was
therefore the mildest one ever
introduced into new hampshire
interestingly many states red and blue
alike
have fetal protection laws more strict
than ours
massachusetts new york nevada hardly
extreme right wing states
had felony
24 24-week abortion bans
the purple states of wisconsin
politically quite similar to ours
currently mandates ultrasounds
throughout the pregnancy and furthermore
requires that women actually view those
ultrasounds
our own modest law does nothing of the
kind
the majority of the committee believes
that changes in the law should be
offered only after a new law has had the
chance to demonstrate itself in practice
not just in ferry
in the hearing a few people gave
testimony stating
in criminalizing those who perform most
abortions after 24 weeks
our state would have trouble recruiting
quality medical workers
to say this ignores two truths
first it assumes all or nearly all
medical workers wish to perform
abortions while we know that many do not
second and more profoundly
for quite some time massachusetts
imposed felony penalties for most
abortions after 24 weeks with no
exceptions for fetal anomalies
nevertheless
massachusetts was routinely ranked as
having the best medical care in the
country additionally
a few raise the question of rape and
incest
research
scientific research
indicates that many victims of rape and
incest take a morning after pill
irrespective of whether that person is
pregnant or not
and in most
every other case
those who do not wish to carry their
baby to term
can choose and do choose to terminate
their pregnancies before 24 weeks
which is six months
moreover we heard testimonies of women
who had been told they were carrying a
child with a quote
severe fetal anomaly unquote
despite being thus advised or in some
cases
pressured
to have an abortion
they chose not to
and the babies they delivered were
healthy and free of any such anomalies
mr speaker i work
some with the dd developmentally delayed
or disabled community
i refuse to see
the dd people
as being
anomalies
finally there have been statements made
that the requirements around ultrasound
are onerous
any confusion about ultrasounds
any scruple about their frequency
or their type such as being invasive
have been adequately addressed in this
amendment
mr speaker i
move we pass the amendment by pressing
the green button
thank you mr speaker
a division has been recalled for so this
will be a division vote
members will take their seats
division
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
me
question before us is on
the amendment
to house bill 1609
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
weber for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that cases of rape
and of incest
and of fetal anomalies which are
incompatible with life
are among the most painful situations
that any individual or any family will
ever face
and if i know that persons of conscience
and persons of deep faith
may be called to different conclusions
when faced with those difficult
decisions
would i now
preserve the rights
of every person
to make that difficult decision
for herself in consultation
with
whomever
she believes
is
an interested and helpful advisor
whether medical professional priest or
whatever
would i now press the red button
to defeat this amendment
chair recognizes representative folsom
for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know that many states around the
country require pre-abortion ultrasounds
all throughout pregnancy
and i know that already our fetal life
protection act
only
requires pre-abortion ultrasounds in
very narrow circumstances
and that this committee amendment
simply reiterates and
re-clarifies the limited nature of the
ultrasound requirement
and if i recognize
that once this amendment is passed and
accept it we will see how many of our
legislators care about the confusion
around
the ultrasound requirement which is very
light
and finally if i
and
i
if i find myself offended
by the fact
that as a woman who has been raped i
cannot think or make a decision
in six months time
would i now press the green button
this is going to be a division vote
the question is on the amendment to
house bill 1609
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
finance
[Music]
so representative kelly
diane kelly excuse me
representative notting wong
representative trelevan
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
[Music]
175 voting yay 177 voting no
the amendment fails
the question is now on the bill that's
ought to pass mr speaker
for what member reason does a member
rise emotion
stage emotion motion to table
motion to table has been made
division has been requested
is that sufficiently second it is
sufficiently second this will be a roll
call vote
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1609
chair recognizes representative weber
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know
that decisions that have to be made
after a rape
after
incest or in the face
of
anomalies incompatible with fetal life
are among the most deeply painful and
difficult decisions that any person will
ever make
and if i want to preserve the rights of
conscience
of every person in this state
faced with those decisions
to the maximum extent possible
would i now vote against the motion to
lay this bill on the table so we can
proceed with the ought to pass thank you
mr speaker
chair recognizes representative mark
pearson for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know
that part of women's health care
is the roughly 50 percent
of the children in the womb who are
female
and mr speaker if i know that
to
turn our backs
on the amendment
would put us out of sync
with many states
and the growing percentage of people in
this country that are pro-life
would i not push the green button to
sustain the table motion thank you mr
speaker
the question before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1609
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
represent moran
representative are you here
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
well i guess i get to exercise my right
to vote again
and i vote yay
[Applause]
also be in order
the motion to table
passes
the clerk has an update on our uh
colleague
thank you mr speaker
as you know during the governor's state
of the state this morning one of our
colleagues had an incident uh he is at
the hospital recuperating um he will be
held overnight but his all signs uh look
good all indications are that he'll make
a complete and full recovery so just
wanted
mr speaker
for what reason does a member rise
representative
b2
uh could you please remind us the
members mr speaker that when they're
making a motion uh people from across
the room may not be able to see who it
is
could they either identify themselves or
could you recognize who has made the
motion so that everyone's aware who's
making the motion thank you
majority of committee on labor
industrial and related data services to
which was referred house bill 1207 fn an
act requiring an employer to provide
paid time off for an employee to vote
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
representative
leno avellini for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment president of andrew manville
for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
manville
thank you mr speaker andrew mannerville
cheshire nine
i rise to support house bill 1207
the goal of this bill
is to aid
and facilitate the ability of our
citizens to vote
it would allow time off for employees
from work for voting
now mr speaker many granite staters have
no trouble voting
they have the necessary time to do so
where they have a good working
relationship with their employers such
that accommodations can be made and this
law
would not affect
any such employees or employers
however
a small percentage of citizens do have
trouble or inconvenience
getting to the polls
given the relationship between their
work shifts and the polling hours
this bill would help
that relatively small percentage of
citizens
i offered an amendment to house bill
1207 in the labor industrial
rehabilitative services committee
amendment 0286h
and this amendment would have provided
various protections to employers
the time off would have been
limited to only up to a maximum of two
hours the employer would receive notice
of
an interest in the time off and would
have had an opportunity for some input
on that and when it took place most
importantly
if the employee had a certain ability to
get to the polls outside of working
hours then this bill would not apply to
that employee or employer at all
now this amendment was voted down
however representative state your point
of order
yes i believe the motion on the floor is
itl
we're hearing discussion of
an amendment i don't believe there's any
four amendment and there is no amendment
to be discussed
with the prevailing motion
the member is correct we need to speak
to the itl not the amendment thank you
mr speaker
the majority objected to this bill
on the basis that employers would be
required to pay
employees for the time off
this would be for a maximum of two hours
at election time
for a relatively few employees
there are 29
at least 29 other states the united
states that have equivalent statutes and
at least 20 of those
explicitly
allow for paid time off and these
include
such conservative states as texas
oklahoma tennessee and utah what is your
point of voter point of art the
gentleman is continuing to speak about a
proposed amendment
the bill in front of us is a three hours
paid off not two hours peter
if you can confine your remarks to
the bill itself and not the uh
my amendment yes thank you mr speaker i
apologize i will i will make every
effort to do so in fact i will do so
this bill would uh place only the most
modest of burden uh on employers
and only in circumstances where the
burden was in great service to our
democracy voting is arguably our most
crucial right it's the right that makes
other rights possible we should all want
to see the maximum number of citizens
participating in our democracy
and we should be prepared to ensure that
this happens
i ask you to vote against this itl so
that another motion can be made thank
you mr speaker
chair recognizing representative time
thank you mr speaker over here at c3
we all want everyone to be able to vote
even if we don't agree with how they're
going to vote everyone should have the
right to vote i as an employer give each
one of my employees an hour off to vote
that's a decision i make as an employer
the
bill in front of us was going to mandate
that employers pay up to three hours
for someone to vote
well
employers
have to take on that burden they may not
be able to afford if they have a small
organization to allow that
and they're not getting the production
time
the labor committee is
very reticent
at putting mandates
on businesses to do something
so while we all hope all employers
will give their employees time to vote
and while we know there's absentee
ballots
and other mechanisms
we feel
this is asking too much
and we are in support of the ito
division has been requested
this will be a division vote members
take your seats
representative del disarro requests the
roll calls that's officially seconded it
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
[Music]
so
the motion before us is in expedient to
legislate
on house bill 1207 this is going to be a
roll call vote the chair recognizes
representative sullivan for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the ability to vote is
equally important as the right to vote
and if i know that paid time off to vote
directly supports this right to vote
would i now then press the red button to
defeat the itl motion so that another
motion can be made thank you mr speaker
chair recognize the representative
infantine for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know we shouldn't put this burden
on employers
would i please vote with the committee
press the green and vote this bill ito
question before us is the majority
report of an expedient to legislate on
house bill 1207
this is going to be a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're approached you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative bradley
representative delemus
representative dolan
representative harley
representative mackey
representative petry
beaumont as president had an opportunity
to vote
i'll attend to the state of the vote
195 voting yay 158 voting nay
committee report is adopted
mr speaker for what reason does a member
rise for a motion
promotion yes sir yes
i move we remove house bill 1609 from
the table
okay
and mr speaker i request a division vote
uh roll call's already been requested by
representative nader
i haven't asked for a second yet but
take
members will take their seats so i can
get an accurate count of a second on the
motion
for a roll call
members take your states
now there has been requests for a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
my
is
the motion before us is to remove
1609 from the table
we have two pis and i would ask those
giving the pis and future pis
that they are pis they're not speeches
they're starting to get a little bit out
of hand
on both sides of the aisle
so
with that
representative i
chair recognized representative weber
for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i desire an opportunity
to vote
on the underlying motion of ought to
pass on house bill 1609
would i now press the green
button
that's a very good pi representative
i hope i hope
house will be in order i hope everybody
takes notice
the chair recognizes representative leon
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the concerns raised about
raped women or women who are a victim of
incest after six months really deserve
different treatment and that abortion at
that state can can cover over abuses
that have happened would i then press
the red button to keep this on the table
the motion before us is to remove 1609
from the table
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative thompson
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
178 voting yay 175 voting a
bill was removed from the table
the motion before us now is ought to
pass
on 1609
we have no debate
and we have a request for a roll call
representative notter requests a roll
call as that's sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
roko
mr speaker
where are you
for what
reason does a member rise
point of order
state your point of order why is it why
is it there's no debate on this motion
nobody signed up for one
nobody knew it was going to come to the
floor
we had a debate on the amendment
there was no underlying debate
the original the original sheep
was a debate on the amendment there was
no debate
on the bill itself
we have the eyes right now
but mr speaker
the the emotion that before us is a lot
different what the motion would have
been on the original bill
so even though
there wasn't anybody to debate ought to
pass as amended
i'd want a debate out to pass i wouldn't
have debated the previous motion
are you asking to speak representative
i'm asking to speak yes
i've already put the question before us
i've already stated that so there is not
going to be a debate
that's that's a parliamentary inquiry on
it
on on both sides
mr speaker a question please
state your question
since the amendment is published in the
uh calendar and the bill is not do we
have copies of the bill here so we know
what we're voting for or against
mr speaker
representative there are no copies of
the bill
of any of the bills present here today
so no there isn't a copy here today it
is online
as every other bill is
further question
is uh mr speaker is a motion in order
what we're in the voting mode right now
all right thank you
members will take your seats members
take your seats we're in the voting mode
chair recognizes representative lakers
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
if i know
that doctors make mistakes
that my cousin was recommended to have
an abortion because her baby had no
brain
and everybody said including the doctor
she had an abortion because her baby had
no brain
and if i know that that baby went on to
college and is now a productive citizen
and the heartache my
cousin would have felt
had she gone ahead and believed her baby
had no brain only to find out after the
baby was aborted that she did
would i
now vote
red thank you
on this bill so people don't go through
that thank you
chair recognize the representative weber
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker if i know
that when faced
with those difficult decisions
every person deserves the right
to make their decision
with the best of medical advice
and that no one
is required under any circumstances
to abort a fetus
but the choice should be preserved so
that every person can act according to
the dictates of their conscience
would i now vote green
on the ought to pass motion thank you mr
speaker
question is on the ought to pass motion
for house bill 1609
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button loading stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
it's working
representative kittridge
representative schultz
representative sylvestre you're all said
baltimore mr president had an
opportunity to vote
will attend the state of the vote
179 voting 174
voting nay
you ought to pass motion
mr speaker i have a motion
this this bill is being referred to
finance
may i make a motion mr speaker what is
your motion my motion is i would like to
move to reconsider our vote that we just
took on 1609 and i urge all the members
to vote no on reconsideration
[Applause]
well if everybody would give me a chance
to speak
i before i accepted representative
webber's motion i have referred it to
finance
so
it's in the possession of finance right
now
thank you mr speaker
house will be in order
majority of the committee on labor and
industrial relative services to which
was referred house bill 1538 fn local an
act requiring prevailing wages on
state-funded public works projects
having considered the same with a report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
senator mark warden for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
president of brian sullivan from the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
abramson
sorry about that i thought it was going
to be a motion
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the itil motion on house
bill 1538 the the member will spend for
a minute
thank you everybody has got the message
that we're in suspension until everybody
quiets down
remember may proceed
this bill house bill 1538 fn only
applies to the prevailing wage on state
projects not local nor private projects
and is therefore within our purview
in purchasing
compared with contractors and consumers
the state lacks the ability to actually
shop around for better contractors and
better workers as private companies and
consumers always do
that's why i believe that we should
privatize as many state activities as we
can however
when we do get down to public works
projects we have a responsibility to the
next generation to build to last to
build durable
and to build well under prevailing wage
contractors hire more experienced higher
wage workers
who
experiences shown waste less building
material and get injured statistically
about 12 percent less often reducing
workman's comp and injury expenses
the result of better work done by more
experienced local tradesmen
is lower maintenance costs and greater
durability as well as keeping more of
the money here in state
since it tends to be new hampshire
workers getting the benefit of the
prevailing wage and cutting the demands
later on social services and charities
michigan did repeal their prevailing
wage law but so no
no net reduction in initial building
costs
another nearby state added the
prevailing wage law and saw only a two
percent two to three percent increase in
building costs since more than ninety
percent of new hampshire's construction
jobs are non-union this is not a union
issue but a matter of merely increasing
wages
by an order of magnitude more than the
initial cost and saving money over the
long run on social services and future
building maintenance redbutton
chair recognized representative
infantine
thank you mr speaker
the prevailing way is wage is determined
when the federal government sends out
information to contractors
asking them to complete them
asking what their division is there's
multiple divisions whether it's plumber
electrician
site contractor fill out the information
what they're paying for a wage and send
it back
if you have a situation where very few
people in the say kawas county send it
back
or maybe one person sends it back
it's abnormally high
or abnormally low
you could set that prevailing wage
which could be any part of the spectrum
twice what the average rate is that's
being paid in cowas county or half of
that
trying to get those prevailing wage
numbers
change through the federal government
takes three to five years
this has not been proven effective
i disagree with what is written in the
blurb that a prevailing wage
allows for new hampshire people to be
hired not at all
if you have a prevailing wage in
rockingham county
it's likely that a maine or
massachusetts contractor will bring in
those residents to do the work
so
when it came to the hearing itself
unfortunately
the sponsor was not able to be there as
he was sick
not one group organization
at all
showed up in favor of the bill
one large group came one person spoke
against it
this does not do some of the things that
people think it does
maybe in a more urban state where
there's bigger cities and what have you
but you do not get the participation in
new hampshire you're not going to get
good data the prevailing wage is not
going to be consistent with what the
wages are and for someone to say that
without a prevailing wage we don't
provide good enough wages for our
employees
i'm sorry
you don't slap me in the face mr speaker
i would ask that
the
members
follow with the labor committee and
press green on itl this bill
a division has been requested
members will take their seats
division
[Music]
so
okay
the question before us is the
inexpedient to legislating motion on
house bill 1538
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
sullivan for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that a prevailing wage statute will
benefit new hampshire construction
workers
and if i further know that prevailing
wage is good for the new hampshire
economy
would i then press the red button to
defeat the itl motion so another motion
can be made
chair recognize the representative
infantine for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know the
prevailing wage does not necessarily
mean new hampshire
workers are going to get paid any more
or any less
if i know that many new hampshire
construction workers are being paid more
than members just south of the border
who do have a prevailing wage
and finally mr speaker if i know that a
prevailing wage would increase the price
of construction costs for new hampshire
department of transportation projects
would i vote
green
with the committee on expedient to
legislate thank you
question before us is the majority
report have been explained to legislator
in house bill 1538
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representable chiller
represent boards
de simone
representative eaton
representative folsom
representative suzanne smith
so
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
182 voting yeah 168 voting a committee
report is adopted
okay
oh okay okay
the committee on legislative
administration to which was referred hb
1586 fna an act relative to a likeness
of wentworth cheswell at the state house
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
gregory hill for the committee the
amendment number is 034
h
printed in house record 6 page 72
the question is on the amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
oppose nay
the amendment is adopted
the question is now on the ought to pass
as amended
the chair recognizes representatives
hill and wall
thank you madam speaker madam speaker i
am pleased to be able to inform you
about a man from newmarket new hampshire
and how this legislation will recognize
his contribution to his community
and the state of new hampshire
february being black history month makes
this story particularly poignant
you see it is believed by some that
wentworth cheswell
is in fact the first black man elected
to public office in the united states
whether he was or not matters little to
those of us who have taken the time to
research a little into the life of this
remarkable man
thank you madam speaker
the original legislation had asked for a
blank check for a portrait to be painted
of wentworth cheswell and to be
displayed in our state house our
committee was not comfortable with the
financial aspect of that arrangement the
bill may well have died but for our very
fine and benevolent group of new
hampshire masons who stepped forward and
offered to commission and pay for the
portrait
the amendment simply authorizes the
joint historical committee to accept the
portrait and find a suitable spot where
it might be
seen in the white house excuse me in the
state house
[Laughter]
we owe a warm appreciation to our house
clerk who is a mason
and for making this a reality and for
pointing out that in addition to all of
his other contributions weren't worth
chase well two was a freemason we ask
that you support the amended version of
this bill
and especially because this is
black history month please vote yes
thank you
the motion on the floor is ought to pass
as amended on hb 1586 are you ready for
the question
all those in favor say aye
oppose nay
promotion is adopted
madam speaker
for what purpose does the member rise i
request that the remarks of the previous
legislators be added to the permanent
journal without objection
no debate nice
the committee on municipal and county
government to which was referred hb 1665
fna local an act establishing a
municipal road and bridge disaster
relief fund having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative richard tripp for the
committee amendment number
03208 printed in house records 6 pages
88 and 89.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
opposed nay
the amendment is adopted
the question now is on
uh to pass as amended on hb 1665 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
oppose nay
the motion is adopted
under the rules of the house it is
committed to the finance committee
the majority of the committee on science
and technology and energy to which was
referred
hb1419fn and act relative to
establishing a new hampshire civilian
climate course advisory commission
having considered the same and report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
representative jose
cambrils
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred hb 1419 fn an act to
establishing a new hampshire civilian
climate course advisory commission
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
that the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative jacqueline
cali pitts for the minority of the
committee for what purpose does the
member rise representative
pose madam speaker i move to lay
house bill 1419 fn upon the table okay
so the motion is to lay house bill 1419
on the table are you ready for the
question a division vote has been called
members we'll take their seats
this will be a division vote
division
okay so the motion on the floor is to
lay hb 14 19 on the table representative
wilhelm is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
if i know that civilian national service
is a powerful public policy tool
that has been embraced by democrats
republicans and independents for decades
and if i know that
the civilian conservation corps of the
1930s and 40s has left a legacy
of bear brook state park and many other
beautiful
natural resources that we continue to
enjoy today
and if i know that there are thousands
of young people
who wish to step up and serve their
community and their country to address
one of the most pressing challenges of
our time the existential threat of
climate change
would i now push
the red button
representative bose is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker madam speaker if
i know that this bill seeks to create a
commission to provide advice
to a civilian climate corps
that does not exist because it was
proposed in national federal legislation
that never passed
but i've now pressed the green button to
lay this bill upon the table
the motion on the floor is to lay hb 14
19 on the table your voting stations
will be open for 30 seconds
so
representative aaron
representative heir
representative belanger
representative bunker
representative long
representative klein knight
representative jonathan smith
representative reed
have all members presents and had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 184 in the affirmative 158 in the
negative
the motion is adopted
it's laid on the table
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred hb 1506 fn an act establishing
a revolving clean energy accelerator
fund in the department of energy having
considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative john lewicki
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred hb 1506 fn an act establishing
a revolving clean energy accelerator
fund in the department of energy having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative rebecca mcwilliams
for the minority of the committee for
what purpose does the member rise
madam speaker i move to place house bill
1506-fn upon the table
representative vo's request delay 1506
on the table
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
division
oh maybe she is
okay
okay the chair recognizes representative
mick williams for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker
if i know
that this bill creates the structure for
a state revolving clean energy
accelerator fund that uses no new
hampshire state funds but rather would
be a bucket set up to receive money to
the tune of 60 million dollars for the
next five years administered by the new
hampshire department of energy with
funds coming from the fed
would i then
press the red button so that a better
motion can be brought forward thank you
the chair recognizes representative bose
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker madam speaker
if i know that the
green bank that is proposed to be
established by this legislation
would make installations of green energy
projects that have been refused by
government and conversion commercial
investors is not financially viable
and if i further know that this
legislation would
violate the state constitution article
two
when i press the green button to lay
this bill on the table
the motion on the floor is to lay 1506
on the table voting stations will be
open for 30 seconds
representative abel
abel
yes not evil
representative conley
representative dolan
representative judy
representative mann
representative marsh
representative teroshan
mother
so
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
with 183 years 166 nays
hb 1506 is laid upon the table
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred hb 1601 fn and act relative to
funding of the new hampshire saves
program having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
nick white for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative peter samsich for the
minority of the committee for what
purpose does the member rise
madam speaker i move to lay hb
1601-fn upon the table
the motion to lay hb 1601 on the table
a division vote has been requested
members will take their seats
your vision
so
uh
no
the chair recognizes representative
oxenham for our parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
the house will be in order
if i know that energy efficiency is the
single most important tool in our effort
to control energy costs eliminate waste
and energy related pollution
and if i know that it also comes at the
lowest cost and is one of the most
effective policy measures available in
our effort to lower utility charges
and if i know that when we waste less
energy we all save money
because we don't need to produce as much
transport as much or trans
transmit as much then wouldn't i support
using the funds provided by the regi
program for their intended purpose
which is to invest in cost-saving
measures that will lower future energy
bills for all ratepayers by hundreds of
millions of dollars
and as the governor said to us this
morning
excuse me as the governor said this
morning not just for today and not just
for tomorrow but for the long term
and in order to do that wouldn't i the
member will suspect
thank you
the chair recognizes representative bose
for a parliamentary inquiry and i ask
for a division vote
it already is
thank you madam speaker madam speaker if
i know
that passage of this bill will raise
everyone's electorate costs would i
press the green button and lay this bill
on the table
okay the motion on the floor is kalei hb
1601 on the table if you're in favor you
will press the green button if you are
opposed you will press the red button
voting stations will be open for 30
seconds
so
representative espitia
representative greene
representative hill
representative hatch
representative bill king
representative judy representative
it's
representative evil
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
180 in the affirmative 167 in the
negative
house bill 1601 would be laid upon the
table
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred hb 1621 fn an act relative to
reducing the rebates distributed by the
energy efficiency fund having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
lex berensky renzi for the majority of
the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
report report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass rep john
mann for the minority of the committee
for what purpose does the member rise
madam speaker i move to lay hb 1621 upon
the table the motion is to lay
1621 on the
table boat has been called members will
take their seats
division
okay
thanks
okay the motion on the floor is to lay
hb 1621 on the table the chair
recognizes representative somsich for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
thank you madam chair
um
well while we just heard this morning
sir yes if i know that i just heard the
governor mention how important
infrastructure is and yet we don't want
to discuss energy efficiency or
renewable energy
and if i know that energy efficiency by
definition is the most cost effective
way to use energy and if i also know
that new hampshire saves
funded through the reggie program only
approves energy efficiency programs that
have been evaluated to provide more
benefits than they cost
if i further know that rebating less to
customers provides
for more funding of energy efficiency to
all residents of new hampshire and
finally when i know that reducing the
demand for energy in new hampshire
reduces both electric bills and
pollution to all residents then would i
now press the red button to uh table to
oppose the tabling motion
the chair recognizes representative
bose for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker madam speaker if
i know that this bill will raise every
ratepayer's electric bill
but i now press the green button to lay
this bill on the table
the motion on the floor is to lay hb
1621 on the table if you are in favor
you will press the red the green button
if you are opposed you will press the
green the red button
the voting stations will be open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative faulkner
representative grota
represent patch
representative hill
representative judy representative
maggiore
representative pearl
representative petrie
representative warden
[Music]
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the boat
183 yays
165 nays
hb 1621 is laid upon the table
for what purpose does the member rise
thank you madam madam speaker i have a
question for you okay
could you tell me
the capacity
of the house table
as to just how many bills
can fit on the table before it collapses
i have been told it is infinite
thank you
the house will be in order
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred hb 1644 fn and act relative to
the placement of telecommunication
antenna antennae and establishing a
registry for residents who are
experiencing biological symptoms from
wireless radiation exposure having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred to for interim
study representative douglas thomas for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority
report with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
lucius partial for the minority of the
committee
the question
on the
floor is interim study the chair
recognizes
the member from marlborough
representative partial
to speak against the committee
report
yes thank you madam speaker
this is a very nuanced subject and i
know that there's not one member
of the std committee that is opposed to
further study
however
the telecommunications industry is not
waiting for our study without
legislative guard rails an interim study
will not prevent 5g roll out
an interim study will be a moot point
once a 5c genie is out of the bottle
with the replacement bill being over a
year away an interim study may conclude
that there are significant health risks
posed by a particular range of mid-band
radiation that would be enhanced by over
saturation of tower placement
with the replacement building over a
year away
an interim study may conclude
our significant security risks by over
reliance on chinese technology
huawei is the world's leading tech
leading supplier of 5g technology
our own nsa cia
and other us intelligence agencies have
concluded that if huawei equipment is
embedded even at the edge of 5g networks
china could easily siphon data off and
uncover their tracks
with the replacement bill being over a
year away
will the member suspend
the house will be in order it's getting
very loud please take your conversations
out into the hallway
the member may continue
with the replacement bill being over a
year away
an interim study
may choose to provide legislative
guidelines
to ensure better coverage than what we
currently face with existing 4g coverage
with the majority of our 911 calls
originating from cell phones
the peril of inadequate 4g coverage
across the state israel
without legislative oversight there is
nothing to prevent the
telecommunications industry from
following the same industry model they
use in 4g and provide dense coverage to
profitable areas while leaving vast
areas of the state unserved
the member will suspend
the house needs to come to order please
take your conversations out into the
hallway
thank you
with a placement bill being over a year
away
an interim study may show that the ftcc
is an overreach
by supplanting local and state zoning
this bill empowers residents and
municipalities to push back an fcc
who recently lost the court of appeals
in the dc circuit court
uh
who called the fcc station standards for
rf radiation arbitrary and capricious
what is previous previously stated
this means nothing if the
telecommunications industry has already
rolled out 5g without any legislative
guidelines
i urge you to vote now
so that an amended bill may be brought
forward that provide legislative
guardrails
thank you and i ask for your division
the chair recognizes the member from
londonderry recommend representative
thomas to speak in favor
of the committee report
thank you madam chairman or speaker
um
this bill unfortunately was an early
bill
and so
it there was no time to to create an
amendment that might have been amenable
to tall parties
this bill as is written would require
towers to be about sixteen hundred and
forty feet away from most public places
this uh i won't say this arbitrary uh
figure but it was a figure that was
developed out of um a commission that
was done
uh it was unclear to us
exactly why that distance was chosen but
we do know that it would affect a lot of
businesses and hospitals if the antennas
and towers were placed that that far
away
we heard testimony from the industries
scientists
that
this technology is safer at a much
closer distance we
heard testimony that
the fcc and the faa and international
organizations have claimed that this
technology was safe
however
we cannot deny
that we also heard and understood
testimony from medical scientists the
public
and
some doctors
that have seen people be affected by
radio waves in various forms
the committee felt that
there may be a correlation between where
people live in radio waves but we are
uncertain as to potentially causation
we felt we needed more time to study
this so that a proper
recommendation could be made that might
be acceptable acceptable to both parties
because of that our subcommittee
recommended interim study
and the committee recommends interim
study i hope the house
votes for interim study thank you
the motion on the floor is interim study
for hb 1644 a division vote has been
requested members will take their seats
division
and first
the chair recognizes representative
samson
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you
madam chair
if i underst if i understand the
sentiment of those who support interim
study because of the lack of information
available
but i also know that a thorough 300 page
report by study commission was already
completed and recommended a safe
distance between 5g polls and
residential areas to be adhered to
so that any health impacts remain
negligible
and if i also know that a bipartisan
amendment is available to temporarily
stop 5g deployment in new hampshire
until numerous unanswered questions are
addressed
and if i know that the new to 5g pole
deployments could require a pole
deployment on every city block
generating its own electromagnetic
radiation
and finally if i further know that the
proposed interim study recommendation
would not even temporarily stop 5g
deployment
and that the results of that study would
be too late for any action to be taken
would i now press the red button to
allow a motion
to pass with amendment to be made so
that 5g deployment can be temporarily
halted in new hampshire
the chair recognizes representative
notter for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you madam speaker
if i know that 5g is an encoding
technology not a frequency nor the power
of the broadcast if i also know that 5g
is a marketing term used to indicate the
next generation of cell phone and data
equipment the member will suspend
i hope there's no videotaping going on
because that's not allowed
okay thank you
the members should be in their seats
thank you madam speaker if i also know
that 5g is a marketing term used to
indicate the next generation of cell
phone and data equipment built on 3g and
4g technology
further madam speaker if i know that we
heard testimony from individuals who say
that certain frequencies make them ill
but other sources testified that this
claim is the result of misinformation
lastly madam speaker if i know that the
claims of illness concerned us enough to
not want to kill the bill but further
study the issue and hear more counter
arguments from the scientists who dispel
the claims would i then press the green
button and send house bill 1644 to
interim study thank you madam speaker
the question on the floor is to send hb
1644 to interim study if you are in
favor you will press the green button if
you are opposed you will press the red
button voting stations will be open for
30 seconds
representative silvestro
represent bleachman
representative macbeth
representative post
representative perez
have all members president had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the boat
with 245 years 140 104 nays the bill
will be sent to interim study
the majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred hb
1100 fn and act relative to changing the
penalties for driving without a license
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is an expedient to
legislate representative ted gorski for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative george sykes for the
minority of the
committee seeing each other easier yeah
madam speaker for what purpose does the
member rise like to make a motion state
your motion i'd like to place 1100 on
the table
the motion on the floor is to lay hb
1100 on the table are you
are you ready for the question a
division has been requested all members
will take their seats
okay
the house will be in order
the chair recognizes representative
sykes for a parliamentary inquiry
madam speaker
and colleagues
this is an important this is a pi
if you know that this is an important
bill
that deserves to be heard in debate
and if you know that there are some
important aspects to this bill that you
may not have yet had the opportunity to
hear i would urge you to vote
red against the tabling motion
the chair recognizes representative
gorsky
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you
madam speaker
if i know
that this statute was changed by this
legislative body back in 2015
in response to a car accident that
caused two
fatalities
by an unlicensed driver
and if i know that this bill passes it
will allow people who never had a
license
to be able to drive a car with limited
impunity
if i know that driving is a privilege
not a right
then i would press the green button
support the table motion
the motion on the floor is to lay hb
1100 on the table
voting stations this will be a division
boat if you are in favor you will press
the green button if you are opposed you
will press the red button voting
stations will be open for 30 seconds
representative abbott
representative ammon
[Music]
representative kelly pitts
representative perez
represent wilhelm
represent weber
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
188 years 161 nays hb 1100 is laid upon
the table
the majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred hb
1208 fn and act relative to driver's
education having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate
rep laura tellurski for the majority of
the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass rep gregory hill for the minority
of the committee
for what purpose does the member rise
for a motion madam speaker state your
motion i move to lay house bill 1208 on
the table
the motion is to lay
hb 1208 upon the table are you ready for
the question
a division vote has been called members
will take their seats
who requested a roll call
representative lang has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded members will take
their seats
the members should be taking their seats
this will be a roll call vote
the house will be in order
okay
okay the question on the floor is to lay
hb 1208 on the table
voting state if you are
if you are in favor you will press the
red green button if you are opposed you
will press the red button voting
stations will be open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative abel
representative boards
representative klein knight
representative salloway
representative sweeney
you're all set up
have all members president had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
209 in the affirmative 141 in the
negative hb 1208 is laid upon the table
okay this is the last bill on the
regular calendar
but we do have some removed from consent
so but we're getting there
the committee on transportation to which
was referred hb 1461 fn enact increasing
penalties for littering having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment amendment and
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass
with amendment representative tom walsh
for the committee
amendment number
02838 printed in the house record 6 page
64.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
oppose nay
the amendment is adopted
the bill is on second reading and open
to further amendment
representative greene offers floor
amendment number 02838
printed in house record 6 on page 64.
and he's recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you madam
chair
i i brought this bill forth to increase
the penalties to keep our beautiful
state clean
and as we see the snow melting away we
see more and more trash on the highways
and by bringing this bill i hope we
clean up our state
thank you
okay so the question on the floor is the
adoption of floor amendment zero two
eight three h are you ready for the
question a division
oh i'm sorry zero six three three
a division vote has been requested
members will take their seats
a roll call has been requested is that
who requested the roll call
representative green requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
that is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote members will
take their seats
[Music]
okay
representative walsh
are you doing a piece
representative green are you doing a pi
no
okay
okay the house will be in order
the chair recognizes representative
walsh for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker if i know this
is the first time i heard about this
amendment would i now press the red
button thank you
the question on the floor is the
adoption of floor amendment zero six
three three h
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations
will be open for 30 seconds
i know it's on page 64. you could read
it
representative we're in the voting mode
if i know that this building i'm sorry
but we're in the voting mode
please take your seat we are in the
voting mode
[Music]
vote green please
the vote is over thank you
representative
representative allegro
contoir representative cushman
representative fenton
representative folsom representative
ford
representative liseles
represent ankerberg
representative vale
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
with 46 in the form affirmative 304 in
the negative the amendment fails the
motion on the floor now is ought to pass
as amended are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
oppose nay
the motion is a dot that gay's habit the
motion is adopted
and it's going to criminal justice as a
second committee
the house will now attend to bills
removed from the consent calendar
the committee on criminal justice and
public safety to which was referred hb
1176 fn
an act relative to reducing the penalty
for sex work within one's own home
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate
representative linda harry at garth
wright for the committee
a division boat
yeah division vote has been requested
members will take their seats
i've signed up for a pi
i know
we're gonna let the members take their
seats first representative
madam speaker
c3
i have a question of the chair
where is c3
for what purpose does the member rise
question of the chair
okay you may ask
could you tell us when you name the bill
out what page it's on in the blue sheets
there's no amendment
no i'm looking i'm looking through the
blue sheets
of the cons off the consent calendar
trying to find this bill
page four thank you
so
the house will be in order
the chair recognizes representative
abramson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam chair and it's just pis
and division for all of these
thank you mr speaker
madam speaker sorry i wrote it down as
mister uh
if i know that this bill only
decriminalized indoor sex work such as
web cameras
if i know that only africa middle east
russia and the u.s arrest large numbers
of women through these sting operations
that violate the privacy of your home
and that africa middle east russia and
the us therefore suffer the highest
rates of human trafficking and the rape
of teenage boys and girls through the
sex trade
and finally if i know that online
polling shows that 65 percent and 77
percent of respondents now support
legalizing prostitution outright let
alone web cameras would i now press the
red button so that another motion can be
made
the chair recognizes representative
abbas for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker if i know that
hb
1176 would facilitate human trafficking
of individuals including human
trafficking of children inside people's
homes
would i go then and go ahead and push
that green button to support the
committee's recommendation of ideal
the motion on the floor
is inexpedient to legislate on hb 1176
voting if you are in favor you will
press the green button if you are
opposed you will press the red button
voting stations will be open for 30
seconds
representative avaloni representative
heir
representative binford representative
bixby representative kretienne
representative ford representative gagne
representative gay
representative gotling
representative harley
representative leishman
representative maggiore
representative mills
representative pearl
representative nunes
representative
salloway
representative turcotte
representative
tripp
representative walsh
[Music]
representative ford are you coming down
to see me
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
319 in the affirmative 28 in the
negative hb 1166 the motion carries
passes
[Applause]
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1340 an act relative to the definition
of domestic violence and relative to
criminal convictions for domestic
violence having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that has been
expedient to legislate representative
amy bradley for the committee
division
this is
a division vote has been requested there
is no debate just pis
members take your seats this will be a
division vote
page five thank you
division
the foreign is on
the report of itl on hb 1340.
the chair recognizes representative
abramson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that new hampshire
if i know that new hampshire is one of
only a few states
that charges roommates and brothers with
felony domestic violence for getting
into a living room fight
if i know that that felony conviction
leads to real prison time and lifelong
repercussions for both fighting siblings
if i know that using the more convoluted
definition and expansive definition of
domestic violence is what has been
clogging up the gun line every few years
which we tried to deal with last session
and most importantly if i know that this
overly broad dimension definition of
domestic violence and domestic violence
laws
have become another back door for gun
control
would i now press the red button to
interim study this important issue
chair recognizes representative abbas
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that narrowing the definition
of domestic violence will create many
conflicts in the law and confusion in
the law
and if i know mr speaker that the
committee
the house criminal justice and public
safety committee was unanimous in
supporting a making a recommendation of
nxp to legislate should i go ahead and
push the green button to support the
committee's recommendation thank you
question before us is the motion of itl
on house bill 1340 this is a division
vote
if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative expedia
represent harley
well members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
322 voting a 26 voting a committee
reports adopted
same things
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1392 fn
an act relative to penalties for
non-violent drug offenses and repealing
the criminal penalties for possession of
drug paraphernalia having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
senator terry roy for the committee
again we have a division vote and just
put parliamentary inquiries members take
your seats
chair recognizes representative abramson
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
by replacing
fines for non-violent drug offenders
by replacing prison time with fines for
non-violent drug offenders this bill
seeks to get the drug problem to pay for
itself
oh i'm sorry if i know
sorry
rather than non-users paying for the
decisions of drug addicts if i know that
57 percent of americans now support drug
decriminalization
if i know that oregon portugal spain
italy luxembourg and holland voted to
decriminalize drugs followed by
reductions in violent crime robberies
overdoses medical costs and death
and finally if i know that 55 years of
repeating the soviet union's failed drug
policy has killed an estimated two to
three million americans or contributed
to their deaths would i press the red
button to end this insane war on drugs
chair recognized the representative
abbess for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker if i know that hb 1392
would make
a
make it a sibilant fraction or a simple
fine of forty dollars for possession of
a lethal amount of fentanyl should i go
ahead and push that green button and
support the committee's recommendation
of index being to legislate
thank you
question before us is the ito motion on
house bill 1392
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative kelly pitts
representative grota
representative folsom
representative fargo
representative harvey
representative o'brien
representative schuett
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
say to the vote
319 voting a 29 voting a committee
reports adopted
committee on executive departments
administration to which was referred
cacr30
enact
officers of the government providing
that the
elected position of inspectors general
are created having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
representative tony leakes for the
committee
this is again a
division vote with just parliamentary
inquiries members take your seats
the chair recognizes representative
abramson for a parliamentary inquiry all
right this is the last one mr speaker
awful loudoun here we're almost done
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that many states
have elected state auditors and
inspectors who investigate waste fraud
abuse and even elections fraud
if i know that contrary to the majority
report's claim
the ag's office dcyf family courts and
election division always claim to have
properly investigated themselves and
found that they've done nothing wrong
if i know that the current process of
investigation does not instill
confidence in our system and finally
if i know that there's overwhelming and
near unanimous support on social media
for electing inspectors general to root
out embezzlement prosecutorial
misconduct no bid contracts cronyism
misuses of impact fees favoritism and
public hiring and firing and in
elections fraud and
election violations would i now press
the red button to send this question to
the voters
chair recognizes
tony leakes for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that
the legislature has the power to
cause investigations to occur on
potential irregularities in either
elections or malfeasance by government
officers
and if i know there's certainly no
assurance that
politically elected inspector generals
will do will solve those sorts of
problems as opposed to uh
you know being influenced by the
political winds of the day
um
and i would and if i know that uh they
would then need offices staff and
everything else else that goes along
with it
would i press the
green button
to
accept the committee recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate thank you
question before us is the motion of itl
on cacr30
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach you press
the red button boarding stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
represent biddeford
represent dolan
represent folsom
representative testerman
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote
also attendance state of the vote
331 voting 15 voting a committee report
is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk
mr speaker uh in a note from the chair
of election excuse me of criminal
justice mr speaker pursuant to house
rule 47 f i hereby waive the second
committee referral of house bill 1461.
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
house bill 1262
in acts
commemorating the 250th anniversary of
the pine tree riot having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
chair recognizes representative mcguire
thank you mr speaker
i pulled this from consent because it
was only there due to my mistake
a member of the committee asked before
we left the executive session that it
not be put on consent and i failed to
make sure that
that it was properly sent to the
regular calendar
i also failed to ensure that the
committee report was accurate as it
appears to have been changed
somewhere during the submittal process
and i'm still investigating how that
happened
but in any event i stand with the
overwhelming bipartisan majority of the
committee in support of the itl
chair recognizer representative earth
thank you mr speaker
states
the governor shall issue a proclamation
calling for proper observance of april
2022 this year as the 250th anniversary
of the pine tree riot
the calendar states
these types of bills are ineffective
because there are many of these type of
events and statute
that are unknown due to the connection
between this event
and the boston tea party
the entire point of this bill
is to bring recognition to this event
for a single day and not every year
for the 250th anniversary
of an event that took place
here in ware new hampshire
that pre-dated
the boston tea party
and was the start of these protests
long-serving representative
gary hopper
an advocate of the history of where
is the sponsor of this
bill i am sure that passing this bill
would put a smile on the face
of a man who has put a smile on so many
of our faces
please vote nay
to overturn the itl
and allow an otp motion to be made thank
you
chair recognizes
chair recognizes representative karate
to
speak for the committee report thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker the eda committee receives
many requests and everyone comes to to
us
with passion and order for their request
and i'm sure that we want to see a smile
on everyone's face
however
it is easy to go to the governor and ask
for a proclamation
from that body
without from that office without
passing a bill through this committee or
this house
therefore i ask the house to support
the
itl motion the bipartisan itl motion of
15 to 2. thank you
state your question i have a true
parliamentary inquiry mr speaker
um
i'm sorry i have to try and figure out a
phrase this correctly
my my parliamentary inquiry is about the
timing
that would be required on a motion
if the itl were to pass
to seek a judicial opinion on whether
this chamber has the authority to
instruct the governor to issue a
proclamation
would
would that be something
that like could that be introduced after
an ought to pass motion was made or
would that motion have to be made
in between an itl and an ought to pass
um
okay
in the past representative i think we've
had numerous types of this legislation
before
and if this was uh as i've been advised
by the clerk if this was to
wanted to be sent to the supreme court
we'd have to kind of lay this on the
table and then move forward with a
separate motion
so
i i haven't actually read the bill
but
if it actually says the governor will do
something that's
kind of a little bit different but
i think almost anybody wants to go to
the governor get a proclamation or a day
name for somebody can do that
all right thank you
um
we have no division in this
all right the motion before us is the
itl motion on hb 1262.
[Music]
are you ready for the question
[Applause]
representative bird has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently second is
officially seconded
this will be a roll call vote
and if i could do a
pi mr speaker
house will come to water this will be a
roll call vote
chair recognizes representative burke
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know
that the pine tree riot
was
the beginning
of this great country
mr speaker if i also know
that the prime sponsor
is in a hospital bed
would i now
vote red
to make him happy
one time
and pass this bill
thank you
mr speaker
recognizes representative mcguire for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know that regardless of the
importance of the pine tree riot and
regardless of any
concerns about making the sponsor happy
that the committee does not believe it's
appropriate to do to pass bill if i know
that if the sponsor had simply asked the
governor to declare this commemoration
i would i would gladly sign it and lay
money that he would do so
so would i now press the green button to
support the committee's rejection of
this unnecessary bill
question before us is the itl motion on
house bill 1262. this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative alessia
representative camarlo
represent walsh
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
two hundred and twenty four fourteen
eight hundred and twenty four of one a
the committee report is adopted
the committee on health and human
services and elderly fiesta which was
referred house bill 1642 fn act relative
to lead testing in children
having considered the same report same
with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator jerry canert
for the
committee
the amendment is zero four four three h
printed in house record six pages eighty
83-84
the motion before us is on the amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
question before us now was octopass as
amended chair recognizes representative
blazik
thank you mr speaker current law
requires every child to have a lead test
i do not question the wisdom of lead
testing but i disagree with any medical
mandate and h.b 1642 takes that mandate
a step further by requiring this test
for school and day care attendance
currently a parent may opt out of the
test but this in this bill does not seek
to change that but i can personally say
that i was never notified by my child's
doctor that this was a state requirement
or that an opt-out form existed
the main argument for this bill is that
there is low compliance with the
requirement to lead test a child
by mandating this test for schools and
day cares the sponsors hope that
compliance will increase
to be clear a lead test has a personal
benefit only and no community benefit it
is not the role of government to force
individual medical procedures on
citizens and i object to any bill that
attempts to coerce compliance by
tricking people
most people like myself are unaware that
they can opt out and if they see a
school or daycare requirement they will
be coerced
in addition by the time a child is
school aged the damage is done
the real focus should be on removing
lead from homes not forced testing after
toxic exposure
government seems to have lost sight of
the true role of public health
we fund dhhs to educate the public
if there is a low lead testing rate that
is a failure of dhhs to do their job and
the solution is not to mandate a test
and ultimately all medical decisions
should be made with informed consent and
are a decision between a doctor and a
patient not the government
get the government out of my parenting
decisions and out of my pediatrician's
office
i urge you to press the red button and
oppose the otp motion
it's getting exceptionally loud in here
again
the members have a right to be heard
chair recognizes representative kenner
thank you very much mr speaker
the requirement for lead testing already
exists in law
this does not
increase the mandate whatsoever
because that requirement already exists
and the process of exemption is already
in that law
parents are allowed to be exempted
it is important to understand that
it is of great public health importance
because
it yes we'd rather catch them one or two
years old but they may go into daycare
at
two years old and that's a good time to
catch them so we can guide
not only treatment because we can treat
them with chelating agents but also to
guide selective remediation
my colleague is questioned about the
fact that we should try to just
remediate all the homes just to
remediate the most troublesome homes in
new hampshire would take approximately
one
billion dollars that's with a b
so it is not realistic to consider that
we will re rehabilitate all of our
housing stock in new hampshire which is
the oldest in the nation so we need to
be able to selectively do it and that
was the purpose of sb247 so we test kids
we get that information we can then
selectively guide
and it is an impact on the state overall
because lead test lead poisoning is a
devastating problem for kids that leads
to enormous costs with
developed neural development issues
so it does not all it does it's a it's a
point of contact to remind the parents
that if the provider hasn't already done
it that they should be getting it done
and there is an exemption that already
exists and that exemption is carried
forward
mr speaker d2
for what reason is remember rise i'd
like to move to table
i would like to request a roll call
representative blazik requests the roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
and i have a piano it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your seats
tabling
the motion before us is
to lay on the table house bill 4 16 42
[Music]
the chair recognizes representative
laser for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that the
focus of public health should be
removing
the underlying issue which is led in
homes not requiring a test years after
the damage is done and if i know that
low compliance with lead testing is a
result of failure of public health
agencies to educate the public
and that medical mandates such as this
simply trick parents into compliance
without informed consent that i would
now vote yes to table this bill
jericho
representative connert for a
parliamentary inquiry
and if i know mr speaker that this does
not add a mandate but instead it is a
reminder at a point of contact that the
testing needs to be done which is
already mandated and for which there are
already exemptions in law and if i know
that changing that really is not germane
to the issue of this bill and ready to
be taken up with a new bill and if i
know that this bill is amended actually
removes of the large scope that was
initially in this bill would i then
vote no
to not table this so we can carry on and
improve the health of our kids and get
the lead out
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1642
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
representative berry
representative kratien
[Music]
representative sylvestro
while members president an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to state of the vote
162 voting a 183 voting a the motion to
table fails
right now our motion is
ought to pass as amended
on house bill 1642
are you ready for the question
a roll call who requested the roll call
representative baldesaro requested a
roll call as that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a role called vote
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on house bill 1642 this is a
roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative bell
disarro for parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
where i stand that we're in the majority
in this room
and mr speaker if i know that many of my
fellow legislators here support freedom
and mr speaker if i know it's about damn
time we stand together and vote this
bill down so we can do another motion
vote red thank you
can we have some silence so we can get
through the rest of the calendar
the chair recognizes representative
kenner for parliamentary inquiry thank
you very much mr speaker if i know that
this bill does not impose a new mandate
but that the requirement for testing
already exists in it this bill is simply
to help
improve the knowledge of the community
that it needs to be done
and if i know that addressing this
exemption process if that is the concern
of people
needs to be
taken up in another session another year
because it's not germaine to this bill
and it already exists in statute
secondary to sb247 from nineteen 19 2000
would i then vote
yes
the green button to support the 20 to 1
bipartisan committee
amendment
support sorry my president committee
vote of otp a thank you very much
the question before us is ought to pass
as amended on house bill 1642 this is a
roll call vote you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative phadolfy
representative mackey
representative ray newman
representative toomey
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
213 voting a 131 voting lady committee
reports adopted
this is referred to the committee on
finance
committee on health and human services
and elderly affairs to which was
referred house bill 1654 fn act relative
determination of pregnancy statistics
having considered the same report the
same
with the recommendation that the bill
would be referred for interim study
senator bill king for the committee mr
speaker
c2
for what reason is remember rise to make
a motion
stage of motion to lay on the table
the motion is to lay 1654 on the table
are you ready for the question
division has been requested members will
take their seats
division
the question before us is to lay on the
table house bill 1654.
p.i mr speaker
chair recognizes representative
stapleton for parliamentary inquiry
i'm asking you to oppose mr speaker
i'm asking that that's not that's not a
parliamentary inquiry
if i know
that we have spent
some three terms
and three iterations on perfecting this
bill and have brought it forward to a
good state
better even than the reporting section
in the recently passed
1069 bill
which only covers 24 weeks this bill
covers
the entire
gestational period
and with better and more perfected
provisions than is in that bill
would i now
vote red press the red button
to uh not lay this on the table
chair recognizes
senator mark pearson for a parliamentary
thank you mr speaker if i know
how much i really want good statistics
for all of the
different aspects of health and welfare
in this state
but mr speaker if i know
the entire committee unanimously said
this isn't ready yet
and if i know we would really like to
make it ready but it isn't right now
would i not affirm the motion to lay on
the table and press green thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is to lay house
bills
1654 on the table
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you post you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent bradley
represent folsom
representative judy
representative huff
representative klein knight
representative mackey
representative sue newman
representative notter represent pimental
representative sandler
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote 275 voting yeah 65 voting nay
the motion to lay on the table
the committee on municipal and county
government to which was referred house
bill
1397 and act relative to a length of
terms for rockingham county officers
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with amendment is in rosemary run for
the committee
the amendment is zero one two eight two
o h printing the house record six pages
sixty two sixty one
the debate is going to be on the
amendment
the chair recognizes representative
ammon
thank you mr chair
uh this this is my sixth year in the
house this is the first bill i've ever
pulled off consent i did so at the
request of a county commissioner that
many of you might know in hillsborough
county
mr robert rowe
this bill um as it stands on the the
committee on the the calendar the title
is misleading the title uh
says it only applies to rockingham
county
but the committee amended it to apply to
every county so
it's taking two-year terms that are
traditional going back to the founding
of the county some of those counties go
back to 1769
the time of the pine tree riots
i had i had uh
office of legislative research look into
the tradition of two year terms they can
go back to the year
back until 1878 we've had two-year terms
for county officials
so this bill if you listen to the public
testimony it was introduced to only
apply to to the county attorney in
rockingham county that was later
corrected to apply to every county
official in rockingham county and then
the amendment on page 60 bottom of page
60 in the calendar applies it to every
county
so we care about democracy we care about
protecting
the voices of our constituents this
would mute their voices
when it comes to county officials
because it would cut their their ability
to vote
in half going from two years which has
been tradition
to four years so they'd be able to vote
half as often
now that might be a good idea in
rockingham county
the association of counties testified in
the public hearing and they said that
this bill is a good test bill it's a
good pilot program
applying only to rockingham county
i agree with that let's see how it works
in rockingham county but don't force the
other nine counties to go from a
two-year term to a four-year term
for a county attorney county treasurer
register of deeds and the sheriff
now focusing on the county attorney in
hillsborough county we had a derelict
county attorney that the ag's office had
to come in take over the account the
attorney's office
actually run the affairs of hillsborough
county's office
if that was a four-year term we would
have been stuck with that derelict
attorney for four years so
we don't want this in hillsborough
county as far as i can tell you might
hear that the counties want it how do we
know that the counties want it did we
take a vote of our constituents or are
we only listening to the people that are
already in power and likely to get
elected again
so
focusing on county attorney it's true
that a county attorney does not make
laws but they uphold the laws that we
pass
and they wield something called it's
called prosecutorial discretion
prosecutorial discretion it's it's a
hidden power in the structure of
government what prosecutorial discretion
is is who do you charge and how how
severely do you charge them they get to
decide that
so not
not having that
position be accountable as accountable
to the voters i think is an issue
i'm not opposing the underlying bill but
i am opposing amendment 120h
bottom of page six yeah i ask that you
vote down the amendment
let this experimental bill go forward
and let's see how it works out in
rockingham county before we force the
rest of the state to do it i asked for a
division vote thank you mr speaker
member yield to questions
sure
send bell to sorrow you may choir
thank you uh representative take my
question it's just a quick one uh on of
course you know we're rockingham county
we fully support this here but when i
was at the meeting are you aware that
nobody from any of the counties came in
and spoke against us
on when they brought this up
so i'm aware i served my first term on
municipal county and it tends to be no
offense to the committee it tends to be
sort of captured by selectmen and
moderators people that listen to the
interests of towns
and counties
the public doesn't always come because
they're not motivated so if we say that
the counties want this how do we know
that the counties want this let's make
it enabling legislation let's make the
counties get to vote on whether they
want a four-year term instead of two for
all the county positions so
uh
i would say take it with a grain of salt
people that are in power they want to
stay in power
two-year two-year terms are good for the
for the governor the executive council
state senate for us and for county
commissioners they all run for two-year
terms this is history going back a very
long time at least to the year 1878
according to house research
why would we want to take this
experimental bill and make the whole
state do it
let's vote down the amendment and let's
have a separate debate on the underlying
bill that would be my recommendation
thank you
chair recognizes representative dolan
thank you mr speaker
this amendment before us now
would assure
our important county officials are
indeed at
work i value
and if i value their hard work
and need their professional assignments
to be focused on
i would be in favor of this amendment
and if i know the sheriff will be
holding a campaign sign
every two years
rather than being in a squad car
arresting criminals looking to break
into our homes
and
put our children and teachers at risk
and if i know our prosecutors ought to
be trying criminals
in front of judges
and not standing on street corners
i will vote this amendment
to assure all county officials all
officials are actively working for our
citizens
this amendment passed
the municipal and county committee by a
vote of 17-2
not a single objection at our committee
hearings
came forward from commissioners
to express their objections
so this is truly a bipartisan
piece of legislation
the 1702
after the amendment passed and and the
committee went on
to achieve a vote of 19 to nothing
and if i know this legislation did not
pass last year because it didn't include
all counties which it does now
i
recommend you vote green to pass the
amendment
the motion before us
is the vote on the amendment
to hb 1397.
the amendment is 012820h
a
division has been requested members will
take their seats
division
so
the motion before us
is on the amendment to house bill 1397
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative airman
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the likely reason no
other county showed up is because the
title of the bill says rockingham county
and not every county
if i know that government is always more
efficient with less input from the
voters
and that's not a good thing
if i know that this amendment is likely
going to be a poison pill on the whole
experimental bill that rockingham county
would like to try
and if i know that two years is good
enough for the governor the senators the
executive council
state representatives county
commissioners it should also be good for
sheriff's county attorneys
register of deeds
and treasurers
and lastly if i know
that a four-year term locks us into
paying them a four-year salary instead
of renegotiating every two years
would i then press
the red button and vote this amendment
down thank you
chair recognizes representative rung for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that this
bill extends the terms for just certain
elected county officers including the
county sheriff
and the county attorney from two years
to four years and if i know that these
positions require professional expertise
and are often full-time jobs
and if i know that a four-year term
provides more stability and focus
to address county needs without the
disruption of biennial campaigns
would i now press the green button to
support
the overwhelming bipartisan vote of the
municipal and county government
committee to pass this amended this
amendment thank you
the question before us
is the amendment 0120h
to house bill 1397.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
[Music]
representative freitas
representative herbert
representative infantine
representative lundgren
representative mackey
representative ray and sue newman
if all members president an opportunity
to vote
house will attend this state of the vote
150 voting a 189 voting a
committee amendment fails
[Music]
the question is now on the motion of
ought to division
who requested that
who requested the division corrosion
representative
thank you
requested a division vote
members should be in your seats we're
going right to the vote
division
the question before us is the motion of
ought to pass on house bill 1397
this is a division vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
represent bradley
represent philadelphia representative
irf
representative lane
representative thompson
representative baxter
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the vote
216 voting a
124 voting nay
the motion of ought to pass
committee on public works and highways
to which was referred house bill 1040 an
act establishing a commission to study
revenue alternatives to the road toll
for electric powered and hybrid vehicles
for the funding of improvements to the
state highways and bridges and their
resulting improvements to the
environment
being considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
representative barry
fulmer for the committee the amendment
is
0.2058 printed in house record six pages
through 53.
is this
all those uh the question before you is
all those in favor of the amendment say
aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative
graham
thank you mr speaker my colleagues i
screwed up
the vote
that is reflected in the house calendar
says 22-0 the actual vote was 20 to 2
and in respect to the two members of the
committee
that voted against it i pulled this off
of consent
so that
the record could be corrected and i ask
that we continue to do the voice vote
and we go to out to pass with the
amendment thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
motion
state your motion motion to
table that is a proper motion
division has been requested members take
their seats
division
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on hb 1040.
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative graham
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i watched the
super bowl last sunday and saw that
every major automobile maker was touting
their new electric vehicles that would
soon be on the road and if i know that
in california and other places they are
already
testing
tractor trailers and big rigs for all
electric travel
and if i know
that this is the future of travel
along with other things besides electric
hydrogen and others
that if we do not get ahead of the power
curve and look at how
we are
going to
fund our roads in the future and if i
believe
that this is the way to do it
with
a commission to look at how or if
we even try to do anything with
alternative fuel vehicles then would i
now press
the red button and not lay this bill on
the table thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is to lay house
bill 1040 on the table
this is going to be a division vote
if you were in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative alexander representative
boards
representative clee
representative howard
representative salloway
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend this state of the vote
85 voting yay 249 voting nay
the motion to table fails
the question now is on emotion of ought
to pass as amended on house bill 10 40.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and the committee report is adopted
committee on public works and highways
to which was referred house bill
1656 fna local
an act establishing a road usage
registration fee
making an appropriation therefore can
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senate david
mills for the committee
mr speaker for what reason doesn't
remember rise for a motion mr stage
motion i i moved to lay house bill 1656
on the table
the motion is delayed
house bill 1656 on the table is a proper
motion a division has been requested
members take your seats this will be a
division vote
the motion before us is to
lay on the table house bill 1656
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative samsich for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i agree with the previous speaker in
support of hb 1040
and if i know that new hampshire's
bridges and roads need extra in revenue
and that the new hampshire dot's 10-year
plan is more aspirational instead of
practical
and if i also know that the
transportation revolution of which the
previous speaker spoke will not be
waiting for two years for us
and the outcome of the hb 1040
commission
and if i
believe unlike the majority report that
this bill does not put the cart before
the horse but quite the opposite
and if i further note it's also
difficult for this body to agree to
raise new revenue despite the needs that
we have
and finally i think it is time for new
hampshire to deliver also on the
promises that it made to 49 locations in
this state
that are negatively impacted by traffic
noise and are still waiting for those
promises to be fulfilled
would i now vote
red against tabling motion
the chair recognizes representative
graham for parliamentary engraving thank
you mr speaker mr speaker if i know we
just voted to have a study committee to
look at road usage fees that this bill
would impose
and mr speaker
if i understand that this bill is
convoluted and doing
vehicle weight vehicle miles driven and
not taking into account whether those
miles are in the commonwealth of
massachusetts or other locales
would i now
vote with the unanimous
vote of the committee
to
lay this bill on the table so that we
can move on and get out of here sometime
today thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the way house
bill 1656 on the table
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're a pose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative alexander
representative grassy
representative infantine
represent mackey
represent pia monte
represent bill boyd
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
of the vote
309 voting aid 29 voting may
house bill 1656 is laid on the table
chair recognizes the member from auburn
representative osborne for the third
reading motion
resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
captions only and that all bills ordered
a third reading be read a third time by
this resolution and that all titles of
bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it be to
meet at the call of the chair
questions on the third reading motion
are ready for the question all those
favors say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it
the house will attend to announcements
chair recognizes the clerk thank you mr
speaker
i would just remind members that we do
have a unanimous consent coming up and
you may want to hold on to your voting
clickers
also
please remember to have your parking
ticket validated if you lost your
tickets
you may exit the left lane when you
leave and speak to the attendant
please make sure you leave your voting
device here
do not take it home with you please drop
it at your party tables
we have one request for unanimous
consent i would ask the members to
please be attentive
chair recognize the representative
branch for unanimous consent
mr speaker
honorable colleagues
i would like to be clear before i start
my speech
my speech is not intended to be
political
but to speak my truth and what i
witnessed and to share the information
with this house and the people of the
state
i believe in truth and democracy are
important to our government and every
aspect of our electoral system including
political parties
i am simply a whistleblower and sharing
my truth
i come before you today as an
independent member of this house to
explain why i left the democratic party
the democratic
i object
remember it member has withdrawn consent
the question is shall the member be
allowed to continue
all those in favor say aye
[Applause]
this will be a division vote
members take your seats this is a
division vote
mr speaker i request a roll call vote
[Applause]
the house will be in order
mr speaker
this is going to be a division vote on
whether the member will
continue to speak or not
mr speaker a roll call has been
requested
i see the hands up so i assume that is
sufficiently seconded
mr speaker
representative lang back here in c3
i just ask that you give us a couple
minutes some members turned in their
clickers and they're retrieving them
they were in the room at the time it
started but they need to get their
clickers so i'd give it a minute or two
the clerk was very pacific in saying
that we're going to have a vote coming
up and if they put them down then
too bad
this is a roll call vote on whether the
member can continue or not
i'm just going to go right to the vote
this is a roll call vote on whether the
member can continue speaking
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
so
figured
at representatives abbess abbott
alexander bailey baldassaro folier
uras fords bouchard burrows caliphates
kaplan chase kretion
cohen contoir
conley
crawford cross
phidolphi fellows fenton font now
goalie gallagher gamarlo gorg
harb harley harrington infantine judy
johnson
canark
ladd
lundgren
luno mckay
mackey
mann mcaleer macbeth
mclean mcwilliams merchant muse
your head
murphy
pimental
rung
sandler chamber
shapiro
janice schmidt
suzanne smith timothy smith sophochetis
sumsitch
sylvia
the burj
toll
tucker
vale
van
von klinsky wazir
welcowitz weston
harvey bullio
and levitt
all right
i didn't call your name
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
199 voting yay
70 voting nay the member may continue
thank you mr speaker
i was told to speak a little bit quieter
and to adjust the microphone
i hope everybody can hear me
i come before you today as an
independent member of this house to
explain why i left the democratic party
the democratic party ironically is the
least democratic institution i have ever
been a member of
for context i served as a member of the
new hampshire democratic party's state
committee since 2020 and obviously as a
democratic member of this house
yet i observed as a leader within this
party is a party that does not follow
the ideals of democracy or follow its
own constitution
the nhdp constitution states that the
state committee shall govern the party
between state conventions
chapter three of the new hampshire
democratic party's constitution states
the purpose of the state committee and
i'm quoting this it is the
responsibility of the members of this
democratic state committee to
participate actively in formulating
policy conducting business and
maintaining the financial stability of
the state party as necessary or
appropriate to carry out the goals of
the nhdp
yep as a former member of the state
committee i can tell you that this was
never followed through on
there was no opportunity for input or
discussion
at any of the state committee meetings i
ever attended
similarly
chapter 2 section b states that the nhdp
conventions shall adopt the platform of
the nhgp nominate presidential electors
vote on amendments to the constitution
of the democratic party promote party
unity and carry out the actions
necessary to further the goals of the
nhdp
this means that the convention is the
ultimate decision-making body of the
party
every single democratic member of this
house
is automatically a delegate to this
convention
as all the democratic members of this
chamber should recall last year's
convention we were tasked with voting on
an amendment to the party's constitution
that included 56
that is 5 6 56
alterations to the constitution
yet the same thing occurred
no delegate was allowed to voice their
opinion and debate this important change
to the party's governing document at the
convention
to make things worse the nhdp office
refused to provide the contact
information
of any state committee member or
convention delegate
to any state committee or convention
delegate
think of it like this
imagine the new hampshire house except
we are not allowed to speak and debate
on the house floor and we are not
allowed to talk to one another outside
of the house
that is the sad reality of the new
hampshire democratic party
to continue with this theme of and
democratic practices
it seems that the chairman of the
democratic party leads his party with an
iron fist
as a member of the state committee we
are tasked with electing the officers of
the party
last year we had such an election
in that election i endorsed and voted
for the chairman's opponent
this seems to have gotten me on what i
affectionately call his blacklist
last year shortly after the officer
election i was running for a seat on my
local school board
in that campaign i faced unprecedented
hatred
from threats of violence to trespassing
to destruction of property
i was going through a lot to say the
least
one such incident was where one of my
supporters pride flags was burnt
after putting their uh
after putting my campaign sign on their
property which was also destroyed that
very same night
although i voted against ray buckley i
still respected him and thought he
i could count on him as the leader of
the party
so i texted him for help with this
situation for help and advice
he responded
i'm busy
send me an email
so i did
i also sent the very same email to the
new hampshire democratic party's office
we're coming up on a year since i sent
that email and i have yet to hear back
from the party
the new hampshire democratic party says
that it stands for minority groups such
as the lgbtq plus community yet when i
as the youngest openly gay legislator in
this country in the history of the
united states reached out for help
i was ignored
these are just a few of the reasons of
why i left the democratic party
now the reason i chose to spoke here
before you today is to educate the
democratic members of this house on the
issues facing their party and to inform
the public of the hypocrisy of the
so-called democratic party of new
hampshire
if you are a democratic member of this
house
and you have seen what i have seen and
agree that the way this party is run is
not right
i encourage you to take a stand and
leave the party as i have until it fixes
its major flaws
when i took my oath of office i did not
take it to a political party
but to our united states constitution
and our new hampshire constitution and
most importantly i was elected to do
what is right for my constituents of
amherst
i want to be very clear this has nothing
to do with the leadership of the
democratic caucus and everything to do
with the leadership of the new hampshire
democratic party thank you colleagues
for listening to me today thank you mr
mr speaker
representative osborne moved the house
stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills enrolled build
amendments and enrolled bill requests
speaker mr speaker are you are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
those both may
the eyes have it
mr house
mr speaker
you make a motion to print the words of
the speaker in the journal
the house is in recess
you